bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat le projet de loi sur la
transition énergétique et bien c'est
l'un des textes phares de cette session
parlementaire la ministre de l'ecologie
ségolène royal en avait présenté les
grandes lignes avant l'été depuis il a
été adopté en première lecture par
l'assemblée nationale mi octobre c'est
un texte qui demande à ce qu'il y ait
une moindre consommation d'énergie plus
de sobriété en allant moins vers le
nucléaire est plus vers les énergies
renouvelables
ce texte promeut également les
initiatives dans les régions mais
surtout et bien il ne veut pas de
l'écologie punitive ne veut pas
notamment de la fiscalité écologique à
l'image de la ministre et au grand dam
des verbes le sénat s'était penché sur
cette question depuis plusieurs mois
déjà organisant des auditions ans déjà
avant l'été dernièrement et bien dans le
cadre de la préparation de ce projet de
loi il a continué ses auditions avec
notamment celle de ségolène royal à
ministre de l'écologie dernièrement
aujourd'hui à la commission du
développement durable présidée par le
sénateur centriste hervé maurey continue
de se pencher sur cette question avec
l'organisation d'une table ronde sur ce
thème regroupant de nombreux think tank
spécialisé tout de suite on prend donc
la direction de cette audition donc
merci à vous d'être
là ce matin merci à nos invités d'avoir
répondu à notre sollicitation
nous avons voulu la commission du
développement durable organisée ce matin
7 cette table ronde avec un certain
nombre de représentants des principaux
c5 sington
pour éclairer un petit peu le débat sur
la transition énergétique
qui
va s'ouvrir au sénat dès la rentrée de
janvier avec le l'examen en commission
du projet de loi qui sera devant notre
devant notre commission au mois de
janvier ensuite dans l'hémicycle au mois
de février donc je le dis pour nos
invités au sénat nous avons opté pour
une solution différente de celle de
l'assemblée nationale où l assemblée
nationale a été créée une commission
spéciale chargée d'examiner le texte au
sénat la solution qui a été retenue
c'est que chacune des deux commissions
concernées par le sujet examine une
partie du texte donc la commission de
l'économie et puis notre commission du
développement durable qui va examiner
toute la partie transport et mobilité
économie circulaire
risque nucléaire énergies renouvelables
et puis également tout ce qui concerne
tout ce qui concerne des déchets et
c'est mon voisin de droite louis
qui est comme vous le savez le
rapporteur de ce projet de loi et qui
fait actuellement un très gros travail
puisqu'il en est une c'est plus combien
de dizaines d'auditions et lui non plus
voilà mais justement pour sortir un
petit peu le pour sortir un petit peu le
nez du guidon pour ne pas avoir
uniquement une approche technique sur
ces sujets on a pensé que c'était bien
de de vous écouter de les écouter et les
écoutons voilà d'élever le débat de
prendre un petit peu de hauteur et un
petit peu de perspective par rapport à
tous ces sujets donc ce matin sont là si
j'arrive pas à lire les noms qui sont
sur les lélés chevalet mais normalement
devrait être là monsieur géraud guibert
que j'ai vu
monsieur arnaud gossement que je vois
qui représente donc la fabrique
écologique qui a beaucoup travaillé et
qui travaille beaucoup sur le rôle des
territoires dans la transition
énergétique et sur l'articulation
justement entre les priorités nationales
et les stratégies territoriales et comme
il ne vous aura pas échappé qu'on est au
sénat et qu'au sénat on est
particulièrement attaché à tout ce qui
compte en les territoires et les
collectivités locales eh bien on sera
évidemment très heureux de vous écouter
notamment sur le modèle de
décentralisation énergétique que vous
appelez de vos voeux
monsieur denis voisins et là qui
représente la fondation nicolas hulot
donc vous avez je crois construit une
déclaration qui met en avant cinq
principes essentiels la réduction des
gaz à effet de serre la maîtrise de la
demande énergétique le développement des
énergies décarbonées la sortie de la
précarité énergétique et l'encouragement
à l'innovation et donc on sera heureux
de vous entendre pour savoir si selon
vous le projet de loi permet d'avancer
dans ce sens et puis vous aurez
certainement aussi des choses à nous
dire sur les enjeux de la démocratie
écologique dans un contexte où la
question de l'acceptabilité des projets
est essentiel et parfois même compliqué
compliqué à obtenir
monsieur jean cau vichy est là
et monsieur brice mallet également donc
vous représentez the shift project cela
qui a l'originalité de croiser je crois
les expertises scientifiques et puis les
enjeux les enjeux économiques et vous
avez élaboré un certain nombre de
scénarios de transition au niveau
national et au niveau européen
nous ne parlerait certainement du projet
de cartographie de la transition carbone
que vous avez initié dès 2012 du
passeport efficacité énergétique et
l'outil que vous proposez sur le sujet
de la rénovation énergétique
et puis de votre projet de société de
financement de la transition énergétique
que vous conduisez avec la fondation
hulot enfin madame jourdan et monsieur
musso qui sont là bas
qui traquent y travaillent sur la
question de la transition énergétique
allemande avec la fondation
terra nova
et je crois que vous insistez beaucoup
sur la dimension européenne de la
transition énergétique et sur
l'opportunité de relance par
l'investissement
qu'elles constituent voilà je crois
n'avoir oublié personne
terra nova
très bien
donc on va on va peut-être vous donner
la parole successivement ce qui serait
bien c'est que vous arriviez à maîtriser
votre propos liminaire dans un maximum
de dix minutes pour qu'il puisse y avoir
ensuite bien sûr un débat avec les
sénateurs ici présents et que vous
puissiez répondre à leurs questions
alors messieurs guilbert et et gossement
donc est ce que pour commencer vous
pouvez évoquer le rôle des territoires
dans la transition énergétique pour
lancer le débat merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs d'abord c'est nous qui nous
revient en version de cette de cette
table ronde et dans cette configuration
et nous nous en réjouissons ça n'a pas
été le cas à l'assemblée nationale ça
n'a pas pu être fait et nous en rendrons
en tout cas dans cette configuration et
évidemment nous en réjouissons très
fortement car nous pensons que ça peut
être en effet tout à fait utile un mot
simplement de présentation sur la loi de
la la la fabrique écologique puisque
c'est une création à ses récentes qui
l'a d'un peu plus d'un an bonjour
appelle les trois principales
caractéristiques
pluraliste et transparente izan est donc
temps dans son conseil d'administration
dans son conseil d'orientation elle a
évidemment des représentants d des
entreprises des ong des syndicats mais
aussi de représentants de 2
les différents partis politiques de
l'arc républicain
et donc c'est une création assez
original puisque les responsables
politiques de la majorité et de
l'opposition sont dans ces différentes
instances la deuxième grande
caractéristique de la fabrique écologie
c'est une exigence extrêmement forte de
rigueur et d'objectivité dans les
travaux et nous avons une procédure de
demande de mise en place de procédures
de validation qui permettent de les
garantir et enfin troisième grande
caractéristique une volonté d'innovation
très forte y compris vis-à-vis de la de
l'articulation entre le travail d
expertise et la concertation avec les
populations puisque nous avons une phase
d' expertise et ensuite nous avons une
phase sur les propositions que nous
faisons de concertation avec la
population pour discuter des
propositions que nous faisons nous en
sommes aujourd'hui à notre huitième note
et donc nous sommes sur un rythme en vie
d'environ six à huit notes parents qui
correspondent assez assez
caractéristique sur le sujet qui nous
occupe aujourd'hui nous avons mené 3 3
catégories de travaux un premier travail
important en effet sur la
décentralisation énergétique
avec un groupe de travail d'ailleurs
très large et représentant l'ensemble
des acteurs nous avons menées à kehl
fait l'objet d'une note tout ça étant
sur notre site tout à fait accessible
très librement à aux uns et aux autres
nous avons fait un deuxième travail sur
la rénovation thermique des logements là
aussi avec toute une série d'acteurs une
note qui a été publié il ya quelques
mois et enfin avec arnaud nous avons co
présidé un groupe de travail pour
examiner le projet de loi sur la
transition énergétique
et à l'occasion de ce groupe de travail
qui a beaucoup travaillé nous avons
proposé une douzaine d'amendements qui
nous ont paru les plus significatifs sur
le projet de loi tel qu'il avait été
déposée à l'assemblée nationale on en
dira un mot parce qu'une partie de ces
amendements ont été repris une autre
partie n'a pas été repris et donc
évidemment on
fera un point très rapide peut-être
devant vous sur les points qui nous
paraissent encore important à signaler
sur ce sujet et donc on va se partager
en effet la répartition du temps de
parole entre entre arnaud et moi même
sur la présentation des trois ou quatre
points qui nous paraissent les plus
importants auparavant je voudrais faire
deux remarques introductives qui me
paraissent tout à fait importante pour
ce pour cette réunion la première
remarque c'est qu'on est dans un
contexte extrêmement mouvant mais un
contexte qui est quand même marqué
depuis quelques semaines par une
extrêmement forte baisse du prix du
pétrole de plus de kaki est passé en
quelques en quelques semaines de 210 de
110 dollars à moins de 60 dollars et il
est évident que toute la stratégie de
transition énergétique et marquer et
peut être marqué par cette évolution
cette évolution du prix du pétrole qui a
certes pour conséquence de rendre moins
rentables voire non rentables un certain
nombre de de production de gaz de
schiste ou de schistes bitumineux au
canada ou ailleurs mais qui a aussi pour
conséquence et qui peut avoir pour
conséquence d'entraîner un coup de frein
important à la la la la stratégie de
transition énergétique par le biais de
évidemment de l'effet prix et de la
diminution de la citation à entreprendre
des travaux d'économie d'énergie on a
connu la même j'irais là même la même
situation dans les années 80 et c'est
vrai que c'est une situation où il ya
vraiment nécessité de renforcer un
certain nombre d'outils et on ne viendra
dans la discussion si vous le souhaitez
parce que si on ne fait rien c'est très
clair on prépare le choc pétrolier
suivant et évidemment on a une stratégie
y compris climatique qui est fortement
handicapé par l'évolution du prix le
deuxième aspect que je veux c'est gagner
sur laquelle toute une série d'entre
nous d'ailleurs pas simplement la
famille écologique à travailler c'est le
fait que il nous ment il manque à notre
avis très clairement une réflexion sur
le cadrage macroéconomique de la
transition énergétique la transition
énergétique est est une stratégie qui
vise à remplacer des flux de matière
d'énergie part du capital
et donc par des investissements
supplémentaires
et donc inévitablement se pose la
question de dans nos économies comment
faire en sorte d'en arriver à un niveau
d'investissements supplémentaires plus
important alors il ya des réflexions qui
ont été menées je suis sûr que nos
collègues en parlerons mais je crois que
c'est un sujet qui reste aujourd'hui
totalement présent et qui doit faire
l'objet de discussions car c'est un
sujet qui aujourd'hui encore extrêmement
mal extrêmement mal réglée alors je
viens directement au sujet ce qui
évidemment vous intéresse le plus qui
est que nous avons nous mis sur le sujet
sur la gouvernance je dis simplement un
mot sur un autre aspect auparavant qui
est l'aspect isolation thermique des
logements ou une série d'amendements
qu'on a proposé ont été retenus et sont
actuellement dans le projet de loi ce
qui nous semble aujourd'hui encore
insuffisant et je crois que vous êtes
tous ces élus locaux je le suis moi même
et on le ressent très fortement dans
l'eau dans nos territoires
c'est le la stratégie de lutte contre
les logements je dirais passoires
énergétiques
il faut je crois distinguer très
clairement dans la précarité énergétique
les quelques millions de personnes qui
sont en situation difficile parce que l
on une facture énergétique de plus en
plus élevés et les gens qui en plus sont
dans des situations de passoire
énergétique c'est-à-dire de logements
pratiquement indigne ou non des sens sur
le plan de et qui peuvent être chiffrés
on les a pas identifiés et c'est ça hein
d un des sujets enfin qui peuvent être
plusieurs centaines de millions de
jeunes de milliers de logements qui sont
dans cette situation et de ce point de
vue là le texte apporte un élément
important puisqu'il classe le il
introduit le critère énergétique dans la
décence des logements donc c'est un
élément important mais ça ne nous paraît
pas suffisant à notre avis est tout à
fait nécessaire d'avoir été un
dispositif d'identification de ces
logements en particulier à partir de
jeudi rai 2 2 le le fait qu'à sa bande
de gens viennent demander des aides
viennent solliciter des aides parce
qu'ils n'arrivent pas à payer leur
logement et il nous semble que dans le
dispositif actuel on ne regarde pas
de manière suffisante en tout cas dans
ces situations là qu'est ce qui pourrait
être fait non seulement pour les aider
bien entendu mais aussi pour faire le
minimum de travaux dans les logements
qui permette que cette aide ne se ne se
prononce pas année après année alors que
sans doute une un volume limité de
travaux pourraient permettre en tout cas
de soulager un peu ces situations voilà
donc ce problème reste entier on avait
fait une proposition d'amendement qui
est à votre disposition et qui avec par
exemple l'intervention de le premier
stade étant une identification de ces
situations de logements elle est à votre
disposition mais ça nous paraît un sujet
relativement important ce qui commence à
être traités mais qui à notre avis n'est
pas suffisamment bien traités alors le
deuxième sujet c'est évidemment le sujet
de la gouvernance nous sommes dans une
situation et je de ce point de vue là la
réflexion que nous avons fait dans nos
notes est très claire nous sommes dans
une situation où inévitablement compte
tenu de l'évolution technique va se
développer des énergies décentralisées
inévitablement compte tenu toute une
série d'évolutions techniques je passe
on pourrait en parler longuement c'est
inévitable a à rythmes différents selon
les catégories d'énergies renouvelables
ou décentralisée mais inévitablement ça
va se développer de manière
décentralisée et donc inévitablement se
pose le problème et va se poser de plus
en plus le problème dans l'avenir de la
cohérence du développement de ces neiges
de ces énergies jeunes désastre
décentralisée d'une part avec l'
architecture du réseau de et électriques
il n'y a pas que des énergies qui
débouche sur l'électricité il ya des
énergies décentralisées qui débouche au
delà chaleur sur d'autres choses mais en
tout cas certaine débouche sur
l'électricité et d'autre part la
cohérence avec je dirais ce qui fait le
modèle français de les centres à 2-2
énergétique français et qui nous paraît
plutôt à sauvegarder parce que c'était
ce sont des atouts que sont la
péréquation et la continuité du service
public et donc ça a été la base de notre
réflexion de savoir comment arriver à
concilier cette nécessaire
décentralisation énergétique avec les
grandes caractéristiques
du système français sachant
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez un système
totalement déresponsabilisé
puisque vous avez officiellement des
collectivités locales et en particulier
les régions qui sont chargés du
développement
par l'intermédiaire de la confection de
schémas territoriaux du développement
des énergies décentralisées ou
renouvelables mais il n'y a aucune
attaque articulation entre ce qu'elles
peuvent apprendre entreprendre dans ce
domaine et les conséquences que cela
peut avoir sur les réseaux ou les
conséquences que cela peut avoir en
termes de contribution au service public
de l'électricité dont chacun sait que
le volume augmente très rapidement ces
dernières années et donc notre
proposition notre réflexion a été
comment arriver à rendre de la cohérence
au système si d'ailleurs on n'arrive pas
à avoir un une évolution cohérente
on voit bien quelle pourrait être
l'évolution incohérente et qui viendra
un jour où l'autre l'évolution
incohérente à notre avis incohérente
étant que tout simplement quelques
grandes métropoles prennent en main la
distribution d'électricité et d'énergie
mais de manière incohérente puisqu'on
sait bien que pour avoir une démarche
assez cohérente dans ce domaine il faut
une certaine solidarité entre l'urbain
et le rural pour parvenir à un système
relativement cohérent donc nous avons
proposé la ligne directrice qui est unie
d'artistes de réflexion pour l'avenir
qui n'est pas forcément nous on aurait
préféré évidemment qu'elle puisse
avancer plus rapidement que mémé qui
n'est pas forcément aujourd'hui à mettre
en oeuvre dans la loi mais qui devrait
s'en fout l'avenir on a proposé une
ligne directrice qui serait un système
qui soit
l'équivalent du système sncf ter c'est à
dire concrètement les régions étant
autorités organisatrices des énergies
décentralisées à la fois pour la
production et pour l'ajustement du
réseau de distribution à l'évolution de
ces énergies décentralisées ces régions
passant convention avec l'opérateur
national erdf pour mettre en oeuvre ses
orientations mais région et en prenant
en charge financièrement grâce à
grâce à une part du tarif de
distribution du turpe prenant en charge
financièrement l'adaptation du réseau à
la distribution alors si on veut pas
aller jusque là à ce stade qu'ils
méritent de réfection on a fait nous on
a voulu mettre le pied dans la porte de
la réflexion mais qui méritent de la
réflexion en tout cas le projet de loi
nous paraît de ce point de vue là 13
très insuffisant puisque la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
est une qui est une des nouveautés du de
la gouvernance du projet de loi est une
est une stratégie totalement descendante
et c'est pour ça que nous avons proposé
des amendements pour qu elle l elle
intègre les les schémas des régions qui
est un espèce de dialogue entre les
régions et l'état pour parvenir à une
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
qui prennent en compte de manière très
claire les stratégies régionales en
matière de de stratégie énergétique nous
avons par ailleurs proposer des
amendements y compris pour que des
régions voire des autorités locales au
dessous de région puisse par exemple
prendre en charge financièrement le
raccordement au réseau ce qui
permettrait je pense d'aller vers plus
de cohérence progressivement dans ce
domaine des énergies décentralisées
voilà tout ça est à votre disposition
les amendements sont son sont sur la
table et sont sur notre site et sont à
votre disposition voilà les quelques
réflexions sur le président que je
voulais faire et je passe arnaud la
parole à arnaud gossement sûre en tout
cas sur deux autres aspects qui nous
paraissent importants delà du projet de
doigts et et qui mérite réflexion
allez-y
bonjour monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs chers collègues
quelques observations cette fois ci plus
valeurs plus juridique puisqu'il s'agit
de mon de mon métier sur trois petits
points la gouvernance juste pour
compléter ce que vient de dire monsieur
guilbert et puis les déchets les
énergies renouvelables sur la
gouvernance effectivement la fabrique
écologique a souhaité souligner le fait
qu'il y avait un paradoxe nous sommes
dans un contexte de réforme territoriale
que le sénat connaît bien de fusion des
régions
et de discussion du projet de loi
portant nouvelle organisation du
territoire de la république et le lien
entre le texte qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui ces deux autres textes n'est
pas nécessairement fait ça c'est un
premier regret et le deuxième regret
c'est que le texte transition
énergétique reste effectivement dans une
logique du haut vers le bas à l'article
48 à partir de l'article 48 on vous
propose trois outils de pilotage de la
transition énergétique
le budget carbone
la stratégie nationale bas carbone et
ensuite la programmation pluriannuelle
de l'énergie en soit ces outils
paraissent très intéressant notamment
leur caractère pluriannuel pour la ppe
problème ils sont tous les trois adoptés
par décret donc si l'état c'est
l'administration qui va décider de ces
trois projets alors j'entends à
l'assemblée nationale dire il faut être
efficace et aller vite sauf que
lorsqu'on ne fait pas cette consultation
des régions nous risquons d'avoir des
incohérences de planification du
territoire qui engendre des complexités
des incohérences des contradictions donc
le temps qu'on a peut être gagné en
amont on va le perdre en aval or les
régions sont chefs de file en matière de
climat et d'énergie depuis une loi du 24
janvier 2014 et les régions dans le
cadre de la loi notre nouvelle
organisation du territoire de la
république vont avoir la planification
grâce aux strates le schéma régional
d'aménagement et développement durable
du territoire qui va inclure le plan
déchets et les schémas régionaux climat
air énergie de telle sorte qu'on va
avoir une planification l'énergie par
les régions et une planification de la
transition énergétique par l'état sans
lien entre les deux et nous avons
proposé des amendements pour y compris
dans un temps court que les régions
soient associés au projet au moins deux
ppe de manière à ce qu'ils puissent
donner leur avis et aussi que les
conseils régionaux puissent s'assurer de
la cohérence entre leurs propres projets
et les projets nationaux jeu on peut
tout à fait imaginer un délai du type
vous avez six mois passé six mois avis
favorable on connaissait endroit ça pose
absolument aucun souci certes on va
perdre peut-être quelques mois au tout
début et encore c'est pas certain mais
ça va permettre d'avoir un porté à
connaissance et une meilleure
articulation entre niveau de
planification deuxième point sur la
gouvernance nous le chef de l'état
appelle un choc de simplification or là
qu'est ce qu'on voit dans les différents
projets de loi c'est aussi des nouveaux
schémas des nouveaux plans on pourrait
aussi grâce à cela peut-être
limiter la profusion des différents
plans schémas mesures limitées les
contradictions de manière à simplifier
un peu tout ça je pense que le sénat
peut être sensible à cet objectif de
simplification et très sincèrement mais
là messieurs je pense que l'avenir c'est
le schéma régional unique on est en
train d'aller vers l'autorisation unique
il faut aller vers un schéma régional
unique pour donner une vraie compétence
aux régions avec des orientations qui
s'impose au niveau infra régional de
manière à simplifier tout ça la
complexité c'est d'abord la
planification endroit c'est pour ça que
je me permets de faire une incise le
projet de loi macron propose des mesures
de simplification au stade projet c'est
beaucoup trop tard c'est au niveau de la
planification à l'origine des choses
qu'il faudrait effectivement pouvoir
faire de la participation du public et
réduire le nombre des schémas tout petit
insiste donc sur la gouvernance le
deuxième point sur lequel nous avons
réfléchi toujours dans une optique de
savoir où sont les territoires ce sont
les déchets
le projet doit partir de l'article 19
comporte un titre sur l'économie
circulaire et les déchets avec une
définition
que nous avons porté qui a été enrichi
par les députés mais nous avions proposé
une définition d'économie circulaire qui
intègre explicitement à l'article 19
l'échelle territoriale pertinente cette
définition nous paraît en l'état actuel
des choses bonnes j'attire vu juste
votre attention sur le fait qu'il y ait
un autre article qui est quand même très
intéressant qui va permettre de faire en
sorte que l'économie circulaire ne soit
pas un slogan à la mode c'est l'article
19 terre puisque dans l'article 19 ter
vous avez la commande publique la loi es
est-ce que vous avez voté récemment
l'été dernier permet de demander aux
grands pouvoirs adjudicateurs on va pas
embêter les petits maires avec ça les
grands pouvoirs adjudicateurs
essentiellement les régions de créer un
schéma de promotion des achats publics
responsables
mais dans son état actuel dans la loi us
s il ne comporte qu'un volet de
réflexion sur l'économie sociale et
solidaire ce qui est très bien de
l'assemblée nationale a accepté et c'est
elle une les propositions que nous
avions porté la fabrique écologique d'y
inclure une réflexion sur l'économie
circulaire il s'agit pas aujourd'hui
d'imposer il s'agit de proposer aux
pouvoirs adjudicateurs une réflexion qui
va permettre derrière à terme de définir
des critères d'achat en matière de
marchés publics les marchés plus que
c'est quand même près de 4 milliards
d'euros par an c'est un levier
considérable pour encourager des
économies locales ce sont ces
entreprises locales ces circuits courts
ces entreprises de recyclage qui vont
permettre qu'ils vont bénéficier de
cette planification des achats publics
voilà donc c'est plus une prise de
parole là pour vous proposer de ne pas
toucher à l'article 19 terres en fête
qui me paraît effectivement assez
intéressant dernier point sur la partie
des chez moi personnellement je me
félicitais la fabrique écologique aussi
qu'il y ait un titre sur les déchets
l'économie des déchets participer à la
lutte contre le changement climatique on
oublie trop souvent le problème de ce
titre sur les déchets c'est que on voit
bien que le législateur aujourd'hui ne
tranche pas sur la manière dont il
souhaitait gérer
j'ai déjà suffisamment embêter monsieur
louis avec cette histoire là mais
ray poupart ep il ya un moment donné où
il faut un petit peu choisir je sais que
les élus locaux ça suscite souvent des
débats s'est passionné et ça a beaucoup
de sénateurs sont très informés de ces
questions sur faut-il les nouveaux éco
organismes faut-il étendre le périmètre
des filières de recyclage de
responsabilité élargie du producteur
dans le texte on tranche pas notamment
sur une question cruciale qui est celle
des déchets du btp il ya effectivement
un mécanisme qui est proposé de
récupération chez les défier certains
distributeurs de certains déchets du btp
je pense que le sénat l'a vraiment pour
avoir une plus value en disant voilà
concrètement aujourd'hui il a collecté
et le traitement des déchets notre
modèle c'est celui ci on tranche or là
on voit bien qu on adapte je vous donne
un exemple article 21 par exemple alors
on veut pas de nouveaux éco organisme
est en fait porté par les éco-organismes
la charge du financement de la
prévention amont et aval de la
production de déchets alors ça va être
donc très bien pour certaines filières
pas pour d'autres vivent des situations
d'inégalité et puis le problème os x et
que certains éco organismes vont
demander à leurs adhérents de l'argent
qu'ils vont rendre à leurs adhérents je
pense aux éco-organismes de déchets pro
qui n'ont pas à faire aux collectivités
territoriales il ya une sorte de boucle
très circulaire cette fois ci on va
demander à des producteurs de l'argent
qu'on va la rendre ensuite l'article 21
me paraît incohérent du point de vue
juridique donc voilà pourquoi parce
qu'il n'y a pas de politique claire sur
au niveau des territoires qu'est ce
qu'on fait en matière de collecte et de
traitement des déchets dernier point sur
les énergies renouvelables là aussi
c'est l'occasion cette loi de deux
tranches et des débats vifs polémique
passionnel je pense notamment à
l'énergie éolienne avec je pense deux
axes possibles petit 1 il faut améliorer
la planification on devait le faire la
suite du grenelle avec les schémas
régionaux climat air énergie c'est un
relatif échec des j'attire votre
attention sur le fait que le tribunal
administratif de paris le 13 novembre
2014 a annulé le schéma régional éolien
d'île de france ce qui fait peu d donc
une insécurité juridique sur les autres
schémas et pas que le schéma régional
éolien le conseil concernait également à
reprocher au schéma régional climat air
énergie de ne pas suffisamment
encadré la participation du public or ça
serait plus intelligent de faire la
participation du public en amont au
moment de la planification qu'en aval au
moment du projet où on a des enquêtes
publiques qui attire personne sauf des
personnes qui ne changeront pas d'avis
et un pauvre commissaire enquêteur qui
subit les observations des uns et des
autres on pourrait donc déplacé la
participation il faut la garder au stade
de projet mais la met plus en amont
comme le conséquence ionel le propose et
le conséquence ionel clairement
aujourd'hui appel à l'utilisateur donc
vous à repenser la participation du
public en matière de planification
territoriale climat air énergie c'est
dommage que l'assemblée nationale se
soit pas saisie de cette décision à la
suite d'une qpc du conseil
constitutionnel deux tout petits
derniers points en général quand on dit
ça c'est qu'il faut s'inquiéter parce
que l'orateur a pas fini
sur
tarn ans j'observe effectivement cela là
je vous promets que même si c'est dur de
limiter un avocat en temps de parole
l'ajout point que ça sur l'éolien je
pense d'abord qu'il apprenne de
planification pour apaiser les esprits
avoir une participation plus en amont
comme je vous disais deuxième point il
faut simplifier ce régime
en matière d'énergies renouvelables
aujourd'hui tout le monde est perdant
ceux qui sont posées au développement
des énergies renouvelables ont
l'impression d'être consultés abandonnés
ou les jeux sont faits et ceux qui sont
pour ce sont confrontés à une montagne
de normes absolument inouïe on pourrait
simplifier tout en améliorant la
concertation et en ne laissant pas les
élus au milieu de tout ça un
amendement avait été proposé à
l'assemblée nationale que nous avions
porté également pour faire passer
l'énergie éolienne du régime de
l'autorisation lourdes l'origine de
l'enregistrement
aujourd'hui les porcheries et hier les
installations de stockage de déchets
inertes sont pas ses origines
d'enregistrement il faut m'expliquer
pourquoi néo liège aujourd'hui
considérés endroits comme nettement plus
dangereuse qu'une porcherie est aussi
dangereuse qu'une raffinerie ou un
incinérateur je pense qu'on pourrait
tout à fait en consolidant la
participation à mon avoir un régime
d'enregistrement en matière d'éolien et
puis alors la somme nationale fait une
mesure de simplification c'est sur la
loi littoral mais c'est tout et puis ce
qui est un petit peu dommage aussi c'est
de ne pas donner de d'un peu d'éclairage
aux autres filières j'attire juste votre
attention sur le fait qu'il y a un
problème dans cette loi puisque en
matière d'obligation d'achat
l'état clairement indique qu'il veut
passer du système actuel d'obligation
d'achat un système de compléments de
rémunération
bon c'est une recommandation la
commission européenne pour une fois la
france sera très proactive et va
transposer avant même que le texte soit
publié une recommandation de la
commission à peine pourquoi pas sauf que
il n'y a rien dans la loi sur la période
transitoire donc on va créer de
l'incertitude pour les investisseurs
quel qu'il soit quelles que soient les
énergies renouvelables et lorsque la loi
va être publié au journal officiel
seules les installations d'énergies
renouvelables listés par décret auront
droit à l'obligation d'achat or le
décret aujourd'hui on ne sait pas où il
est et ce qui veut dire que les
autorités en charge de l'obligation
d'achat principalement edf demain
pourront enfin quelque part je leur en
veux pas une lecture juridique pour être
de dire j'attends de savoir quels sont
les installations soumises au bénéfice
de l'obligation d'achat pour pouvoir
leur en faire bénéficier j'ai été
beaucoup trop long je vous remercie
c'était très intéressant mais c'est vrai
qu'il faut essayer de de limiter le
temps de parler parce que vous êtes
assez nombreux qu'il ya un certain
nombre de sénateurs qui ont beaucoup de
questions à vous poser est donc il faut
risque d'être un peu rabat joie mais
j'ai ce triste ce triste rôle ce matin
je vais vous demander d'essayer d'être
le plus bref possible monsieur voisins
donc qui représente la think tank de la
fondation nicolas hulot
je vous donne la parole faisait
peut-être préciser quels sont pour vous
les principes à respecter pour une
véritable transition énergétique
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs oui j'ai 4 4
points sur lesquels je vais j'ai insisté
particulièrement sur ce projet de loi
transition énergétique le premier
concernera la fiscalité le deuxième le
bâtiment mobilité et puis et puis sur la
démocratie puisque vous avez invité à
parler un peu de gouvernance même si ce
n'est pas mon domaine de prédilection et
être à titre personnel nous en tout cas
en tant que fondation nicolas hulot on
est on est plutôt satisfait du texte qui
est sorti de l'assemblée on avait fait
une trentaine de propositions dont
beaucoup ont déjà été intégrées dans
dans ce texte je vais pas je vais pas y
revenir ici mais il reste quand même
beaucoup de choses à préciser à
améliorer voire des choses a intégré
puisque n'ont pas du tout été intégré
une chose qui a été faite à moitié et
sur lequel je voudrais insister au début
de mon propos c'est finalement c'est cet
article a été inséré sur la fiscalité
équipe qui fixait l'objectif de procéder
à un élargissement progressif de la part
carbone dans la taxe intérieure de
consommation sur les produits
énergétiques vous savez qu'on a mis en
place en france puis à cette année film
en 2014 cette taxe carbone enfin
finalement qu' une part carbone dans
l'athéisme c'est quelque chose de très
important il ya une trajectoire qui est
prévu jusqu'au bout jusqu'à 2016 et nous
dans le cadre de ce projet de loi qui
fixe des grands objectifs de long terme
il nous paraissait essentiel de faire
figurer finalement un objectif aussi
d'évolution de cette fiscalité carbone
encore plus aujourd'hui dans le contexte
où on a un prix du baril qui qui
baissent fortement et donc la question
se pose d'autant plus sur ceux de ce
point de vue là et donc on sait que les
travaux qui ont été conduits
précédemment par de nombreux groupes de
nombreux groupes d'experts fixé
l'objectif finalement 200 euros par
tonne de co2 en 2030 pour aller vers le
ver le facteur 4 pour être en phase on
sait que c'est un levier puissant à la
fois pour favoriser l'innovation pour
favoriser la réduction des émissions et
donc c'est quelque chose qui pour nous
est important et qu'on vous demande
peut-être de réintégrer finalement dans
cet article il s'agirait juste de
préciser
voilà le comité de qualité écologique
avait fait des propositions qui aillent
dans ce sens
l'année dernière et puis il va être
relancé bientôt pour continuer à
travailler sur ce sujet
un autre point sur la fiscalité c'est
aussi de permettre finalement
collectivités locales d'expérimenter on
a vu que ça a déjà pu commencer à être
fait mais d'expérience et de certaines
choses en particulier mon oncle a
demandé récemment aussi dans la
conférence environnementale mais à
l'écotaxe oui effectivement il faudrait
perdre il faut permettre aux régions par
exemple expérimenté cette écotaxe c'est
aussi des mesures
qui sont liées à la cuisson et la
pollution de l'air qui pourraient être
mises en place suite au développement
d'un système d'identification des
véhicules polluants donc ça c'est un peu
c'est le premier sujet sur le bâtiment
très rapidement nous on a deux on a deux
priorités qui n'ont pas pas été traitées
complètement l'idée d'avoir un grand
plan de rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments de l'état ou en tout cas du
parc du parc tertiaire public mais je
laisserai du coup plus de schiste
project parler de lille et de l'île de
ly départ donc on pousse le sft mais ici
dans ce dans ce projet de loi on
pourrait pour le moins mentionné
finalement l'obligation pour le
gouvernement de présenter au moins un
rapport qui détaille sa stratégie en
matière de rénovation du parc de son
parc du parc de l'état à l'horizon 2050
l'autre point important c'est la
précarité énergétique dans le bâtiment
on sait qu'il ya des objets via des
objectifs chiffrés qui sont qui sont
affichés il faut aussi préciser les
moyens
d'y arriver qui reste à préciser qu'ils
sont pas très claires dans l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui la politique qui est en
oeuvre n'est pas suffisante pour
atteindre ces objectifs qui sont souvent
répétés mais on voit qu'on a du mal à
progresser et que la précarité
énergétique se développe
aujourd'hui
le sujet sur lequel j'aimerais le plus
insisté puisque finalement celui qui a
été le moins bien prises en compte dans
ce projet de loi l'état actuel at elle
qui le soir de l'assemblée c'est la
mobilité
alors on sait qu'en plus vous avez la
chance de bénéficier finalement des
travaux qu'on pu être conduits dans le
cadre de la conférence environnemental
où il ya une table ronde dédiée à la
mobilité donc monsieur lune avec vous si
vous y étiez
avec beaucoup de propositions
intéressantes et qui est qui vous donne
née voilà des pistes pour enrichir ce
texte il ya des choses qui ont été
faites sur les sur les véhicules propres
des obligations qui ont été mises
d'ailleurs pour certaines certaines
flottes privés etc qui sont
intéressantes il ya un point qui nous
nous paraissait finalement assez facile
à faire c'était celle oblige à une
obligation d'équipements pour les
collectivités en termes de véhicules
propres elle a été renforcée on sait
qu'elle est non contraignante
une obligation qui existe depuis la loi
alors finalement qu'à jamais été jamais
été respectées parce qu'il n'ya pas il
ya pas de ya pas de contraintes il n'y a
pas de sanctions donc nous proposer
simplement de d'introduire une sanction
est minime et qui serait avait faim
financière et qui serait affectée
justement un fonds pour le développement
des véhicules propres donc d'introduire
cette ce genre de mesure je vous
donnerai les détails de nos propositions
d'amendements parleurs par la suite un
des gros points aussi qui et qui a paru
finalement surtout suite à la conférence
environnemental c'est le diesel on sait
qu'on a eu on a eu un discours très
attendu du premier ministre sur ce sujet
et puis que des collectivités aussi
prennent des initiatives dans ce sens
ici il ya deux choses pour nous qui nous
restent qui reste à préciser dans ce
texte on sait que ce texte introduit une
prime à la conversion en échange d'un
vieux véhicule diesel on pourrait avoir
des aides pour acquérir des véhicules
propres
mais si on a en a un sujet acquis qui
nous préoccupe beaucoup puisque les
modalités de cette prime ne sont pas
assez clairement définies dans ce texte
ces envoyés à des décrets et le gros
risque d'avoir finalement une politique
on a besoin pour sortir diesel d'avoir
une politique aussi sociale on sait
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont en
situation de précarité énergétique dans
l'âme dans leur mobilité qui ont des
véhicules d elle il faudrait donc cette
aile cette politique doit ceci doit se
ciblées sur ces gens là non mais on
n'est pas là pour aider des gens
finalement
acquitté leurs vieux véhicules des ailes
pour acheter un véhicule neuf mes
propres c'est-à-dire électriques ou
hybrides c'est des véhicules très
coûteux et donc a priori pour nous cette
mesure est elle rate sa cible on devrait
voir une mesure qu'ils soient
conditionnées à compte du fait qu'il
soit sous conditions de ressources
qu'ils soient plus importantes mais
qu'ils soient qui permettra aussi
d'acheter des véhicules d'occasion plus
performant c'est à dire qu'on doit quoi
voilà quitter un véhicule diesel très
polluant pour acheter un véhicule
d'occasion plus performants type euro 4
donc c'est des choses que le
gouvernement s'est engagé à étudier mais
ça nous paraît important d'insister
danseuse dans ce texte puisqu'il ouvre
ses prime à la conversion de préciser
cette démarche de bien de bien cadrer
cette démarche en disant que c'est aussi
une mesure de lutte contre la précarité
énergétique dans la mobilité un autre
point donc ce que vous avez pu discuté
récemment une proposition de loi 2 la
sénatrice aline archimbaud sur le diesel
qui proposait dans son article 2 il me
semble qu'ils étaient finalement assez
intéressant qui soulignait un point
qu'on a qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est le
grand écart qu'il ya entre les émissions
réelles des véhicules diesel là je parle
de véhicules neufs on sait qu'ils sont
beaucoup plus beau football qu'ils ont
beaucoup amélioré leurs performances
mais il reste un point
sur lequel je lui attire notre attention
c'est le grand écart qui entre les
émissions réelles qu'on peut mesurer sur
la sur la route quand ces véhicules
roulent et puis les émissions qui sont
faites sur banc d'essai dans des tests
d'homologation là dessus on sait que
c'est pas ça a été prouvé par beaucoup
d'études c'est plus quelque chose qui
est qu'ils discutaient finalement
scientifiquement sur les nox en
particulier il ya les vrais il ya des
vrais écarts qui sont qui sont très très
conséquent et sur lequel de l'alem
l'adieu aussi d'ailleurs sur lequel il
faudrait se baser aujourd'hui pour
conduire les politiques publiques c'est
à dire que c'est c'est c'est aujourd'hui
pour nous avez rendu coup d'avoir des
politiques par exemple que le bonus
malus qui sauf qu'il qui se base sur des
tests dont on sait que finalement il
correspond pas à la réalité derrière ça
c'est quelque chose sur lequel ce projet
de loi russie auxquels ils pourraient
remédier
sera encore sur la mobilité d'autres
points plus rapide il ya quelque chose
qui avait fait consensus dans le cadre
du débat qui préparait finalement ce
grand texte dans le débat sur la
transition énergétique c'était l'idée
d'une étude sur l'effet d'une baisse des
vitesses de 10 km heure sur route et
donc pour nous c'est important de
réintroduire finalement c'est une
proposition qui est revenu lors de la
conférence environnementale mais non de
la réintroduire dans ce texte simplement
la région n'est pas de mettre la baisse
des vitesses un mais bien deux mètres au
moins la réalisation de réalisation
d'une étude qui fait le point sur les
impacts environnementaux
enfin les bénéfices environnementaux et
les impacts s'il y en a un socio
économique d'une telle baisse des
vitesses
enfin
deux autres points de deux points sur
les plus réglementaire sur les sur les
pda les u15 ce texte aussi fixe un
objectif finalement de développer les
plans de mobilité pour les entreprises
de plus de 100 salariés ce qui est une
très bonne chose quelque chose qu'on
avait demandé un point qui est apparu
lors de la conférence environnemental
c'est aussi la nécessité finalement de
définir qu'est ce que c'est exactement
ces plans de mobilité comment est ce qu
on les construit au sein de l'entreprise
comment est-ce qu'on ait construit
l'entreprise en lien avec les
collectivités locales c'est quelque
chose qui demande à être précisée
aujourd'hui en cohérence avec cible ce
qui pourra ce qui est ressorti de la
conférence environnementale
enfin sur le dernier point sur la
mobilité c'est au niveau des
performances des véhicules à une part et
c'est aussi important dans ce texte et
ça n'a pas été fait ça n'a pas été fait
précédemment de faire figurer finalement
des objectifs français de performances
des véhicules en termes d'émissions de
co2 et particules on sait qu'au niveau
européen il ya des objectifs qui sont
fixées par des directives européennes on
sait qu'on a on a aujourd'hui un
problème puisqu'on a un objectif qui est
fixé à 2020 il ya l'idée d'abandonner un
objectif finalement pour pour 2025 et
d'europe repoussé plus tard est la
position de la france au niveau européen
à dessus est assez inquiétante et ce
serait bien d'avoir des multi fixée du
coup au niveau national quoi qu'il se
passe au niveau européen on sait qu'il
ya un lobby important des allemands pour
finalement ne pas ne pas avancer au
niveau européen sur les performances des
véhicules en matière de co2 c'est
quelque chose que ce texte pourrait
finalement précisé de lui-même
enfin sur la question de la de la
gouvernance et la démocratie donc je
vais être assez rapide il ya deux choses
dans ce texte qui sont directement liés
à ce texte
pour nous c'est
l'idée est d'assurer une certaine
transparence de la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie en mettant en
place un comité d'experts
pluraliste dont la composition restera à
préciser et puis de relancer ce qui
avait été fait aussi dans le cadre du
débat finalement c'est les comités
citoyens de faire des conférences de
citoyens pour continuer à faire de la
pédagogie sur c'était sur cette
politique énergétique
après ça il ya des choses qui sont
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus vastes comme
pouvait le souligné arnaud gossement sur
la participation sur la gouvernance et
au terrain mais il ya eu un discours
donc à ses engagements du président de
la république là dessus donc il ya un
chantier qui va s'ouvrir sur ce sujet en
tout cas on l'espère et j'imagine que ce
sera dans ce cadre là aussi puisque nous
on va le demande et enfin on pense qu'il
faudrait une loi très clairement sur
cette question-là de la participation du
public et la démocratie participative
et que t'es pas qu'on légifère là dessus
par ordonnance com se propose de le
faire d'ailleurs en partie de la macro
mais voilà qu'on puisse aller plus loin
dans le cadre de ces dossiers de ces
prochains travaux en créant aussi en
poursuivant les travaux qu'on pu être
mené dans le cadre la monnaie de la
monnaie la modernisation du droit de
l'environnement par nous sur ce point là
effectivement sur les projets il faut il
faudrait intervenir en amont il ya déjà
décidé propositions qui ont été faites
et qui ont été faites dans le cadre des
rapports plus haut sur la réforme du
code minier la réponse du crâne du code
minier qui aujourd'hui dont il est
important d'aller mais qui était
intéressante aussi super rapport comment
est-ce qu'on peut réformer le
commissaire enquêteur pour créer des
groupes
d' enquête à durée déterminée qui
reflète les parties prenantes et qui
pourrait qu'ils pourraient sur les
projets d'infrastructures
gérés appel d'offres pour les études et
c'est donc éviter les conflits
d'intérêts qui pourraient aussi définir
les modalités de la porte de la
participation sur les projets sensibles
des choses qui sont intéressantes en
tout cas qui sont à creuser puis sur
lequel on reviendra par la suite mais
c'est pas forcément dans le cadre de ce
de ce projet de loi et oui simplement
pour information j'imagine que vous avez
reçue en hanoune a fait donc deux
publications sur la mobilité donc une
sur mobilité précarité et l'autre sur
mobilité
et la question des territoires
périurbains et ruraux qui en est quand
même relativement différente vous avez
dû recevoir prétendent qu'on voulait la
comme les a envoyés mais je vais vous
lire communiqué dedans il ya beaucoup de
propositions qui justement que son
serait possiblement intégrable dans ce
texte
merci beaucoup je vais donner la parole
à monsieur jancovici ou à monsieur et/ou
à monsieur mallet pour évoquer un sujet
l'important est qu'ils aient souvent mis
en avant sur ce projet de loi la
question du financement et la question
du modèle économique
de ceux de ce projet de loi nous vous
écoutons
ce tarif
merci beaucoup alors nous on est ici
presque par accident on est très content
d'être ici mais on est ici presque par
accident parce que dechy project a
vocation à s'adresser avant tout au
monde économique
à la différence de mes collègues qui
sont ici on n'a pas vocation à
s'adresser en premier au monde politique
et on n'a pas vocation à s'adresser donc
lui en premier aux français
la raison pour laquelle le nom et
anglais c'est que on a vocation aussi à
parler beaucoup au niveau européen tout
à l'heure il a été évoqué la partie
descente vers le bas c'est à dire ce qui
se passe à l'échelon régional il faut
aussi un tout petit peu s'intéresser à
monter vers le haut c'est à dire ce qui
se passe à l'échelon européen la france
n'est pas seule au monde il ya quand
même un certain de texte européen qui
encadre ce que nous pouvons faire est
par ailleurs sur deux sujets dont je
vais vous parler maintenant qu'ils sont
l'approvisionnement pétrolier et gazier
si les français pouvaient décider seul
de la quantité de pétrole et de gaz qui
ne veulent consommer
ça serait beau malheureusement c'est pas
comme ça que la situation se présente
donc nous sommes
nous avons un tropisme économie
extrêmement fort aux schistes project et
notre écosystème premier on va dire
c'est le monde économique qui a envie de
réconcilier la préservation de notre
maison commune avec une fiche de paye
vous savez que nos concitoyens en ce
moment sauf ceux ci un tout petit peu
d'avoir une fiche de paye ça fait partie
de leurs préoccupations qu'on peut
difficilement leur enlever et dans tous
les sondages il vous explique que
l'environnement ils aiment beaucoup ça
sauf qu'une fois qu'ils votent avec
leurs pieds ils vont aller faire autre
chose et c'est normal encore une fois le
monde économique a une importance
centrale qu'on soit tous qu'on ne
souhaite pas être malheureusement un
débat un peu derrière nous dans le dans
les démocraties donc ce qu'on cherche à
faire aussi project c'est cette idée un
peu folle d'essayer de réconcilier des
objectifs environnementaux et les
objectifs environnementaux tels qu'on
les voit ils ont souvent un substrat
scientifique fort
et des objectifs économiques parce que
si on n'est pas capable de dire à qui on
donne une fiche de paye et pour quoi
faire dans un monde qui préserve
l'environnement et bien on reste les
jeux est un peu taquin dans la presse
des beaux quartiers parisiens mais n'a
pas beaucoup avancé
une fois que j'ai dit ça je vais vous
donner quelques éclairages un peu
généraux sur l'énergie et la transition
énergétique art d'abord je voudrais
rappeler une chose toute bête
je suis désolé on n'échappe à son passé
c'est que l'énergie avant d'être un
sujet de débat c'est une grandeur
physique
l'énergie est une grandeur physique qui
mesure les flux donc des vous avez un
flux quelque part de chaleur de
mouvement de réaction chimique etc vous
avez de l'énergie donc vous n'avez pas
de vie sans énergie vous n'avez pas
d'économie sans énergie n'avait pas de
modification sans énergie et inversement
plus vous avez d'énergie plus il se
passe un grand nombre de choses autour
de vous donc la consommation d'énergie
d'un individu n'est rien d'autre que son
aptitude à modifier l'espace qui
l'environnent un plus la d'énergie puis
peut déplacer des objets plus il peut
chauffer et refroidir des objets depuis
que transforme et c'est ce qui veut dire
soit dit en passant que beaucoup
d'énergie propre c'est impossible par
définition le propre c'est toucher à
rien à voir beaucoup d'énergie c'est
transformé beaucoup beaucoup d'énergie
propre ça n'existe pas et très souvent
les énergies propres sont les énergies
infinitésimale dès qu'elles cessent de
l'être et c est propre
une fois que les derniers points
l'énergie comme je disais c'est des flux
et donc c'est notamment ce qui permet
aux machines de fonctionner donc si vous
avez une usine avec des machines et des
ouvriers et pas d'énergie vous n'êtes
pas de production si vous avez une
voiture vendue avec un conducteur est
pas de pétrole vous n'avez pas de
déplacement etc etc donc l'énergie est
un des éléments absolument indispensable
à ce que fonctionne le monde industriel
dans lequel nous vivons et ce monde
industriel dans lequel nous vivons le
parc de machines qui nous environne en
france représente 500 fois la puissance
musculaire de la population 500 poids en
ordre de grandeur si j'additionne la
puissance en permanence à l'oeuvre des
frigos des pompes qui amène l'eau ici
des voitures de l'éclairage des usines
qui sont en train de faire vos vêtements
et vos chaises etc
tout ça mis bout à bout c'est à peu près
500 fois la puissance musculaire de la
population ce qui veut dire que la
production économique est en premier en
première approximation
fonction du nombre de machines la
quantité d'énergie qu'elles mangent et
pas du tout fonction de la taille de la
population c'est la raison pour laquelle
la production économique de la france a
pu pendant un siècle dépassé celle de la
chine alors qu'on est beaucoup moins
nombreux mais pendant un moment on a eu
beaucoup plus de machines que beaucoup
plus grosse et donc ça faisait beaucoup
plus de pib le jour où le nombre de
machines par personne en chine devient
le nombre de machines par personne en
france et bien le pib chinois sera 20
fois le pib français et je vois pas
comment on pourra y échapper
donc le donc le voilà donc l'énergie
c'est ce qui permet à la civilisation
industrielle de gérer ces flux et donc
de gérer derrière la contrepartie
économique de ces flux donc une loi de
transition sur l'énergie c'est une loi
de transition sur la société c'est pas
juste un machin ou il s'agit de donner
trois éoliennes à 3 élus qui ont envie
ou de réacteur 2 - 2 écolo qu'on a envie
c'est pas ça le sujet le sujet c'est que
la loi de transition c'est une loi sur
l'organisation physique de la société
c'est une loi sur le pouvoir d'achat
c'est une loi sur la part des diverses
activités économiques c'est une loi sur
la géopolitique
c'est une loi sur l'europe c'est une loi
sur l'espérance de vie c'est une loi sur
l'éducation et la qualité des soins en
face d'une loi sur tout ça encore par
construction parce que l'énergie c'est
la physique
alors une fois je vous ai dit ça
quelques propos un peu plus généraux sur
l'approvisionnement français on vous a
distribué un petit document j'espère que
vous l'avez dans lequel on vous a donné
la répartition par secteur de
consommation et par nature d'énergie
primaire donc c'est l'énergie comprend
dans l'environnement à l'énergie
primaire de ce qui se passe en france
donc c'est découpé en résidentiel les
bâtiments dans lesquels vous habitez
tertiaire les bâtiments dans lesquels
vous travaillez industrie c'est les
processus industriels donc ce qui permet
de faire de l'acier de transformer
derrière etc
les machines qui sont dans les chances
c'est l'agriculture enfin les machines
qui servent à déplacer des marchandises
ou à déplacer des gens et on a mis pour
chacune de ces barquettes en milliards
de kilowattheures d'où venaient
l'énergie primaire qui permettait
d'alimenter les machines en question est
ce que vous constatez très facilement
sur ce graphique c'est que l'essentiel
de l'énergie qui permet à la france de
fonctionner comme elles fonctionnent
aujourd'hui il vient des hydrocarbures
pétrole et gaz de très loin devant
l'électricité de très loin devant
l'électricité si je regarde d'où vient
la matière qui permet à l'énergie des
disponible en france eh bien vous voyez
que sur la partie énergie finale ou et
45% c'est du pétrole qui n'est pas
produit en france 25% c'est du gaz qui
n'est pas produit en france vient
derrière le nucléaire l'uranium n'est
pas non plus produit en france mais
alors que nos importations de pétrole et
de gaz nous coûte actuellement alors le
pétrole vient de baisser donc l'année
dernière
nous a coûté 70 milliards d'euros le
radiant nous en coûte 1 donc certes on
importe mais enfin les ordres de
grandeur sont pas exactement les mêmes
même le charbon beaucoup plus cher que
l'uranium
et bien évidemment c'est les
combustibles fossiles qui sont à
l'origine de la totalité de nos
émissions de co2
l'électricité non fossiles quelle
qu'elle soit ni concours que peut elle y
concourt au moment de la fabrication des
moyens de production bien évidemment et
éventuellement des sites amont et aval
les deux graphiques que vous avez à la
suite vous montrent que le pétrole et le
gaz sont déjà en décrue suivi en europe
donc aujourd'hui l'europe perd à peu
près 2% de son pétrole par an parce que
la mer du nord est en déclin et parce
que la production mondiale nonobstant
les gaz de schiste des pétroles de
schiste à peu près flat depuis 2005 je
dis bien à peu près flat depuis 2005
est donc là par un portable par l'europe
est en baisse puisque la consommation
domestique des pays producteurs et la
consommation des pays émergents est en
hausse donc là par un portable de
l'europe est en baisse donc que
l'automobiliste français on ait envie ou
pas pour le moment la quantité de
carburant qui rentre en europe baisse de
2% par an en gros
et je ne vous ai pas mis un autre
graphique qui pourtant est très
intéressant si vous regardez comment
évolue la quantité de pétrole consommé
dans le monde et le prix du pétrole sur
un siècle il n'y a pas de lien entre la
quantité disponible et le prix ça peut
vous paraître étonnant il n'y a pas de
lien entre la quantité disponible et le
prix donc quand les gens vous disent le
prix du pétrole baissent c'est donc on
va en avoir plein c'est faux de même que
quand ils vous disaient le prix du
pétrole monte donc on va en manquer
c'est faux des deux sont faux d'accord
il suffit de regarder les séries longues
pour le savoir et ce qui est en train et
là où je suis d'accord avec géraud
guibert c'est que ce qui est en train de
s'annoncer la maintenance et prochain
choc et la prochaine récession c'est
juste sa quête en plein de s'annoncer en
ce moment
vous avez également un
jeu bon je fais là juste une incidente
mais j'y reviendrai en conclusion
puisque on parlera de financement la loi
de transition malheureusement je pense
doit s'inscrire dans un paysage
économique qui sera désormais sans
croissance voire en récession
structurelles donc toutes les mesures
dans la loi qui suppose que l'on va
avoir plus d'argent public en gardant
tous les usages publics qu'on a déjà par
ailleurs pour financer quelque chose en
plus ce sont des débats qui sont loin
d'être évident alors ça peut
éventuellement aller de pair avec un
endettement croissant s'il est affecté à
quelque chose qu'on estime absolument
indispensable enfin un jour ou l'autre
l'endettement croissant dans une
économie sans croissance ça se termine
par de l'hyperinflation par du défaut et
si c'est pas de l'hyperinflation ce sera
du défaut
donc ce qui concerne le gaz le gaz est
également en déclin en europe depuis
2005 et j'attire votre attention sur le
fait que pour le gaz comme pour le
pétrole le déclin a démarré avant lehman
brothers donc l'idée qu'on consomme
moins de pétrole parce que c'est la
crise est une idée à laquelle je ne
souscris pas je pense que d'abord nous
avons eu moins de pétrole et qu'ensuite
on a eu la crise et que c'est bien dans
ce sens là que les choses se sont
écrites du reste depuis que le pétrole
s'est fortement ralentie en termes de
production mondiale c'est-à-dire les
chocs pétroliers 74 à 79 vous le savez
bien puisque vous allez examiner le
budget tous les ans c'est de cette
époque là que débute le problème de
l'endettement de l'état et de
l'augmentation difficile à endiguer du
chômage dans ce pays
donc ce n'est pas d'abord j'ai une
croissance venue de mars et ensuite je
consomme de l'énergie c'est d'abord j'ai
de l'énergie est ensuite j'ai de la
croissance et si j'ai moins d'énergie
mais j'aurai une récession ou quelque
chose qui y ressemble
les flux industriels dans tous les pays
de l' ocde sauf les états unis sont à la
baisse depuis 2007 c'est à dire depuis
le moment où l'approvisionnement
énergétique des pays d'où cedeao a
tendance à baisser
je vous ai également rappelé que si je
regarde combien on a dépensé en france
pour importer du pétrole et du gaz sur
les 20 dernières années on est à peu
près dans les eaux de l'augmentation de
la dette souveraine de la dette de
l'état français depuis cette époque là
donc on n'est pas en train de parler de
petites sommes une fois que je dis tout
ça la conclusion majeure évidemment à
laquelle je vous amène c'est que la loi
de transition doit avoir ce qui n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui pour objectif
premier de débarrasser l'économie
française du pétrole et du gaz
or pour le moment c'est essentiellement
une loi sur l'électricité c'est à dire
ce qui de notre point de vue ne pose pas
de problème majeur pour le moment
pourquoi est-ce qu'on en est arrivé là
je vais pas vous apprendre votre métier
vous savez très bien que les grands
objectifs de campagne ne correspondent
pas nécessairement l'application de la
règle de trois
bon alors
ça a suivi que le fil de l'eau
dans cette affaire qu'est ce qu'on
propose donc on propose de décarbonés
l'économie alors décarbonés l'économie
va se faire pour une très large part par
des économies
et pour une part non négligeable
par du changement de mix mais nous du
chiffre on n'est pas du tout pour que
l'on baisse nucléaire on pense que c'est
pas la priorité loin s'en faut dans le
contexte actuel
je laisserais après une intervention bri
revenir sur ce qu'on propose de plus
précises sur leur rénovation thermique
du logement je vais vous donner la
philosophie générale de ce qu'on propose
la première chose dans notre philosophie
générale c'est que nous sommes désormais
dans une course contre la montre c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui si on reste les bras
croisés on n'est pas dans un contexte
dans lequel on préserve le pouvoir
d'achat et le pib français on est dans
un contexte dans lequel on assiste à sa
lente érosion à cause de ce que j'ai dit
sur la décrue du pétrole et du gaz donc
en gros le temps joue contre nous
et par ailleurs tout argent dépensé là
où ça n'est pas utile par effet
d'éviction supprime la possibilité de le
dépenser là où il est utile dans un
monde en croissance on peut faire à la
fois des trucs intelligents et des
bêtises dans un monde sans croissance
plus on fait de bêtises et moi on fait
des trucs intelligents
malheureusement encore de l'arithmétique
bête et méchante
donc ce qu'on pose sur le bâtiment c'est
d'obliger on propose d'obliger les gens
à rénover alors on le propose de la
manière suivante cd que vous touchez un
bâtiment vous êtes obligé d'embarquer la
performance thermique dans ce que vous
faites donc on va pas vous dire rénover
le sénat demain matin par contre le jour
où vous toucher au scénar vous êtes
obligé d'embarquer la performance
thermique dans ce que vous allez faire
c'est ça l'idée
il ya une voiture balai à bas tout le
monde devrait y passer il ya une voiture
balai qui passe derrière qui est que il
ya un niveau minimum de performance à
respecter pour les bâtiments au fur et à
mesure que le temps passe c'est à dire
que alors on n'est pas tellement le dpe
parce que l'énergie finale a plus de
sens pour les particuliers mais peu
importe c'est ça revient à dire que en
2022 il n'y a plus aucun bâtiment classe
g qui circulent et puis en 2025 qui n'a
plus aucun classe f et puis et c'est ça
l'idée est donc de voiture balai et on
propose de concentrer les aides
uniquement sur ceux qui ne peuvent pas
faire face économiquement à cette
obligation
donc le cadre supérieur il a pas besoin
crédit d'ing il se passe très bien de
crédits d'impôts ça sert strictement à
rien ça nous rejoindre que de l'effet
d'aubaine
les dons qu'il faut obliger tout le
monde est concentré les aides sur ceux
qui ne peuvent pas
soit dit en passant dès qu'on mélange
plusieurs objectifs dans une même
politique en général on a de bonnes
chances d'atteindre aucun et ça je le
dis pour la question difficile certes
mais de la précarité énergétique où on a
tendance à mélanger de trucs et à penser
que la précarité énergétique se traite
par le prix de l'énergie c'est la
dernière des bêtises à faire il faut le
traiter par n'importe quoi sauf le prix
de l'énergie
pour moi qu'il dit ça ça date d'il ya 25
ou 30 ans sur le tertiaire public
on a poussé très fort un projet qui se
retrouvaient soit dit en passant en très
bonne place dans les propositions faites
par la france à la commission européenne
dans le cadre du plan jeunes coeur donc
sft eux qui a été fait en initié avec la
fmh
et qui en gros vise à profiter je veux
pas rentrer dans les détails aujourd'hui
mais vise à profiter d'un mécanisme qui
a été mis en place pour entre guillemets
le sauvetage des banques à la suite de
la crise de lehman brothers la sfef ça
vise à reproduire le même genre de
mécanisme pour faire intervenir de la
garantie publique non consolidées dans
maastricht pour avoir la possibilité
d'avoir des financements à des taux très
bas pour la rénovation du tertiaire
public qui a l'énorme avantage d'offrir
de très grosses surfaces d'un seul
tenant et donc de perfer de permettre de
mettre en branle les gros acteurs du
bâtiment qui sont par construction ceux
qui peuvent se lancer en premier sur un
marché un peu neuf donc l'idée c'est
qu'il ya que dans le tertiaire public
que vous avez l'ap-hp offre des dizaines
de milliers de mètres carrés d'un seul
tenant ça peut faire des très gros
marché dans le cadre de ppp ou les les
gros peuvent prendre le risque de la
performance alors qu'avant que l'artisan
du coin de la rue prennent le risque de
la performance dans la rénovation du
logement il va encore se passer un
certain temps
le deuxième chose que on pousse donc je
laisserais aubry se redire sur la partie
logement ces deux décarbonés les
transports décarbonés les transports se
fait de deux manières fin de trois
manières
alors je vais faire beaucoup de peine à
louis je pense que l'électricité
c'est la troisième et la dernière voir
la 4e et la dernière les deux les trois
choses qu'il faut faire avant c'est
juste pour vous donner une idée les
déplacements en voiture c'est un tir de
missile travail un tiers mobilité du
quotidien hors domicile travail un tir
longue distance en gros là dedans le
plus essentiel à la stabilité sociale du
pays c'est le déplacement domicile
travail si les gens peuvent parler au
travail on a quand même un petit souci
pour ça il faut massifier en faisant des
réseaux de bus express autour des
grandes villes c'est ce qui en termes de
capital investi et le plus efficace est
de très loin et c'est ce qui permet
d'utiliser les routes la route du pardon
qui est une infrastructure déjà là si
vous regardez la consommation en capital
qui est nécessaire pour passer la
voiture sur le rer nous serons tous
morts dans cette salle qu'on ne sera pas
encore
donc il faut passer sur le bus il faut
descendre très très vite la consommation
des voitures en circulation et ça ça
veut dire qu'il faut forcer par la
réglementation un maximum de
consommation des véhicules neufs vendus
et simultanément une pro mettre en place
la vignettes donc en gros si les gens
qui ont de l'argent ont toujours envie
de rouler dans une voiture qui consomme
beaucoup grand bien leur fasse mais il
faut qu'une taxe annuelle à la détention
qui monte très vite et simultanément il
faut offrir aux gens qui n'ont pas
beaucoup d'argent des voitures à 2
litres au cent et ça n'arrivera pas tout
seul par les mécanismes du marché donc
là on va aussi avoir un tout petit sujet
qui est la remontée vers le haut à
bruxelles qui est que la concurrence
libre et non faussée pour gérer les
problèmes à 50 ans ça ne marche pas
ne marche pas
et enfin là sur la partie pardon il faut
également préserver le transport
interurbain qui va souffrir puisqu'il
est aujourd'hui fait essentiellement de
voitures et d'avions aujourd'hui il faut
le basculer sur du train parce que les
échanges c'est la paix confer jean
monnet et donc il faut garder un flux
des changes entre grandes métropoles
européennes et le basculer sur le train
l'externalité paix soit dit en passant
mais pas la guerre n'est jamais prise en
compte dans les bilans sociaux
économiques des transports
jamais
c'est très amusant jamais
enfin
il faut décarbonés l'industrie alors
décarbonés l'industrie ça veut dire que
de toute façon les flux de production
baisser parce que je disais tout à
l'heure l'énergie va diminuer donc il
faut faire plus de recyclables plus de
maintenance donc la partie une partie de
l'industrie va basculer sur les services
c'est normal c'est je maintient en vie
des objets plus longtemps du coup je les
fabrique -
et enfin un concept que on commence à
pousser au shift c'est celui très
étonnant pour une bande d'ingénieurs de
los teques c'est à dire que si on veut
pouvoir modulariser et recycler plus
vous êtes high tech c'est à dire plus
vous faites des trucs sophistiqué et
intégrée et plus vous avez de mal à
retrouver dans l'objet les éléments
élémentaires qui peuvent être réutilisés
pour faire autre chose
donc le grand paradoxe de cette affaire
c'est qu'une partie de la solution peut
être high tech mais une partie aussi est
justement los teques
voilà on
je vous ai donné encore une fois moi
j'ai pas discuter les articles pris un
par un par contre je vous donne un
paysage un peu large qui est celui de
l'esprit général de la loi et
malheureusement aujourd'hui je considère
que l'esprit général de la loi ne répond
absolument pas aux urgences du pays on
est en train de s'offrir un débat qui
est un luxe dont nous n'avons pas les
moyens
je laisse s'en est jamais vraiment
rapidement parce que le temps passe que
reste encore à écouter
terra nova donc après on a on a beaucoup
de questions déjà qui se sont manifestés
donc vraiment très rapidement monsieur
mailly s'il vous plaît merci monsieur le
président je donc
vous propose de donner quelques
remarques pour limiter en temps de
parole sur on a évoqué plusieurs fois le
terme de précarité énergétique je veux
juste rappeler que
le lab lutte contre la précarité
énergétique est une politique sociale
qui mérite toute l'attention de la
puissance publique
mais qui n'apporte pas grand chose sur
le débat énergétique entente est long
tous les cas ne répond pas exactement à
nos enjeux de consommer ce 2 de deux
heures de lutte contre
le co2 pourquoi parce que ayant les
ménages qui sont en précarité
énergétique sont très fortes
restrictions et donc les gains qu'ils
sont opérés sur des gains de confort je
pense beaucoup d'autres d'en trouver
autour de la autour de la table savent
mais juste rappeler encore une fois que
il ya souvent confusion entre lutte
contre la précarité énergétique c'est
une politique sociale encore une fois
qu'ils méritent toute l'attention mais
ça n'est pas une politique énergétique
en tant que tel pour les besoins de de
co2 le deuxième point c'est sur le
carnet numérique on avait fait une
proposition il ya plus d'un an
maintenant qu'ils avaient été reprises
nous n'étions pas exactement les seuls
mais cette proposition de passeports
efficacité énergétique ou rénovation
thermique pour accompagner sur la durée
les logements avaient été reprises par
le premier ministre de l'époque jean
marc ayrault et ensuite
évoqué dans différentes instances
aujourd'hui dans la loi il ya le terme
de carnets numérique
d'entretien suivi et l'entretien tout ça
par type exactement du même concept
c'est une bonne chose je juste attirer
votre attention sur le fait que sur le
terrain les acteurs professionnels de la
filière et même
les collectivités sont un petit peu
perdues sur l'ensemble des termes qui
sont utilisés on parle de carte vitale
pour le plan bâtiment durable de
passeport pour ce qui nous concerne et
d'autres d'autres fils d'autres acteurs
de la filière de carnets numérique ici
de carnet d'entretien par ailleurs pour
les copropriétés dispositif qui existe
déjà et donc un moment il faudra à mon
avis que les acteurs
de l'état les acteurs publics pour une
lisibilité de la politique sur le
terrain rassemble un peu la terminologie
et et concentre un peu la communication
vers un dispositif que tout le monde
comprend et qui est un peu généralisés
donc que ce soit un ter - ou un autre
peu importe il faut que que ce on y
viennent deuxième point est peut-être je
terminerai sur ceux sur cet aspect là
haut niveau il y a des
objectifs qui sont fixés dans la loi
certains
ambitieux le cadre général ait défini il
n'en reste pas moins vrai qu'une bonne
partie du succès de cette loi en fait
n'est pas dans la loi en tant que tel
aujourd'hui mais dans les décrets
d'application et l'ensemble des
dispositions qui vont sortir après et je
veux juste attirer l'attention sur l'un
d'entre eux c'est ce qui concerne les
niveaux de performance énergétique pour
ce qui est de la réglementation
thermique de l'existant qui n'est pas
évoquée dans le texte mais mais qui est
en fait déterminant pour le gain de
performances des logements dans les
années qui viennent
ce que vous savez bien que pour ceux qui
l'enjeu n'est pas dans les bâtiments
neufs qui sont déjà soumis la rt 2012 et
ça n'est pas non plus sur les très
grosses rénovations qui sont très peu
nombreuses mais c'est vraiment l'enjeu
réside dans le diffus est
essentiellement la maison individuelle
pour ce qui est du résidentiel c'est là
que ça se joue et encore une fois ce
sont les critères de performance qui
seront dans cette rt ex pardonne moi
c'est un peu technique mais c'est c'est
ça qui va déterminer en grande partie si
la trajectoire pour le résidentiel
privé merci merci beaucoup donc je donne
la parole aux représentants de terra
nova qui vont peut-être maintenant
aborder la question de la dimension
européenne la transition énergétique
le tout dans un délai le plus bref
possible raphaël ont souhaité que tout
le monde s'exprime dans un maximum de
dix minutes donc voila merci beaucoup
donc nous sommes trois pour terra nova
commente ainsi via ma droite pierre
musso à ma gauche et moi même et ses
terres jour dans le pôle énergies terra
nova a publié plusieurs notes sur les
sujets qui nous occupe évidemment n'aura
pas le temps de tout les présenter mais
je vous en mentionne les thèmes pour
pour référence une note sur les marchés
de l'électricité une note sur la
transition énergétique en allemagne une
note soit petit gazières européennes la
rénovation énergétique des logements le
marché du carbone la précarité
énergétique et la question des
investissements
aujourd'hui ce le point principal sur
lequel on vous propose d'insister c'est
la question des investissements et je
vais introduire le propos développé le
premier point et je laisserai la parole
à pierre qui développera le deuxième
point est pure à conclure cette cette
discussion
alors pourquoi l'investissement le point
de départ c'est un constat qui rejoint
très fortement celui qui a été partagé
par monsieur jean cau ici c'est un
constat qui dit qu'aujourd'hui notre
croissance économique est très fortement
reliés à la consommation d'énergie
depuis la révolution industrielle
l'énergie alimente la croissance et
alimentent une amélioration de nos modes
de vie et notre confort la question
centrale qui se pose aujourd'hui c'est
celle du découplage vous avez sûrement
entendu ce mot c'est de savoir si on
sait si on peut des couples et cette
consommation énergie et cette croissance
économique et la difficulté à laquelle
on est confronté c'est que on ne sait
pas bien répondre à cette question
pourquoi parce que les modèles qu'on
essaye de mobiliser pour évaluer les
politiques publiques sont des modèles
qui ont deux failles principal la
première c'est que c'est des modèles
qu'ils comprennent qu'ils analysent très
très mal sa dépendance passée entre
énergie et croissance économique
et deuxième faille c'est que c'est des
modèles qui sont basés sur le passé même
si c'est les modèles qu'ils comprennent
mal or aujourd'hui le challenge qui
s'offre à nous c'est d'inventer un
nouveau modèle dans lequel on sait vivre
bien dans un monde fini est donc dans
lequel extrapolé passé pour évaluer
l'avenir n'est absolument pas pertinent
donc on est assez démunis et on a un
choix qui s'offrent à nous et ce choix
il est aujourd'hui dans le projet de loi
c'est l'objectif de diviser par 2
réduire de 50 % nos consommations
d'énergie à l'horizon 2050 avec une
étape intermédiaire qui est de réduire
de 20 % à l'horizon 2030 nos
consommations cet objectif à notre avis
est absolument centrale c'est l'objectif
primordial important de ce projet de loi
et c'est un objectif je suis sûr qu'il
fera débat
et et qui impliquera si on souhaite
n'atteindre et si on veut l'atteindre
soit parce qu'on n'a pas le choix comme
l'a dit monsieur jancovici soit parce
que on estime que c'est un objectif
désirable pour pour notre société qui
nécessitera d'agir à tous les niveaux et
notamment au niveau des investissements
c'est c'est le point principal sur
lequel on invite insisté alors pourquoi
les investissements
aujourd'hui il ya un relatif consensus
qui se dégage à l'échelle européenne qui
est de dire qu'il faut faire de la
relance par l'investissement et que dans
ces thèmes prioritaires sur
investissement le sujet de l'énergie
sera centrale il appartient maintenant à
la france suite aux annonces de plans
qui ont été faits par la commission
européenne fin fin novembre de mettre
vraiment la transition énergétique au
centre de ses projets d'investissement
et se sont emparés de manière efficiente
c'est-à-dire de rechercher
une maximisation de l'impact en termes
de création d'emplois et de valeur dans
le pays en termes de réduction des
apports d'énergie fossile qui pèse très
fortement dans la balance commerciale
est en termes d'efficience de l'euro
publics investis avec une leçon
d'efficacité et une notion si possible
d'impact positif sur les comptes publics
cet investissement il doit passer par
deux grands sujets des investissements
dans la production d'énergie c'est
l'offre et non mais des investissements
dans la demande énergétique c'est
l'efficacité énergétique
essayez les deux thèmes principaux que
nous allons développer donc sur le
premier la production d'énergie bon il
ya des choses en premier dans le projet
loi
il faut pas oublier que energy sse
électricité mais c'est aussi ça a été
dit de la chaleur il n'y a pas pas que
d'électricité dans le mix énergétique
français et les investissements dans le
secteur l'énergie sont importants vous
avez sûrement vu passer un récent
rapport de l'aïe eux qui estiment de
l'ordre de 2000 milliards d'euros les
investissements nécessaires en europe
entre 2014 et 2035 dans le secteur
d'énergie donc c'est significatif c'est
à peu près pour donner un ordre de
grandeur vingt pour cent de plus que ce
qui s'est fait dans sur les dernières la
dernière décennie et ces investissements
sont importants
et son a piloté par le pouvoir public la
décision collective et ce ne sont pas
des investissements qui seront faits par
les marchés aujourd'hui les marchés de
l'électricité en particulier ne
permettent pas du tout de donner les
signaux économiques qui pourraient
générer ces investissements c'est
logique c'est marcher ils ont été
construits dans une logique
d'optimisation mise en concurrence de
court terme de moyens de production déjà
amortis ils n'ont pas du tout été conçu
pour permettre ces investissements dans
le secteur de l'énergie donc il est
nécessaire pour le pouvoir public de
définir les investissements qui sont
souhaitables et ensuite de mettre en
place les dispositifs nécessaires pour
que ces investissements se réalise et
donc d'adapter les marchés pour qu'ils
puissent servir les décisions
collectives ses décisions
d'investissement du secteur d'énergie
ils doivent être faits en prenant en
compte que les objectifs de la
transition énergétique sont multiples et
parfois un peu lente agonie sts il faut
assurer l'indépendance énergétique et la
sécurité énergétique du pays il faut
assurer aussi une certaine efficience
économique de la production d'énergie il
faut préserver l'environnement et donc
tous ces objectifs doivent être pris en
compte il faut que des objectifs soient
fixés pour chacun de ces objectifs et
qu'on soit en mesure de décliner notre
mix énergétique souhaitable à partir de
ces objectifs en quantifiant c'est ce
qui est proposé par la ppe d d'objectifs
de développement
de capacités de production filière par
filière et en révisant ses objectifs de
manière régulière
donc sur le secteur de l'énergie son
électricité + chaleur ne pas oublier la
chaleur des investissements importants
seront nécessaires et il ne faut
absolument pas se laisser
occupés par des signaux de court terme
qui sont ici ont marché les marchés sont
un moyen ne sont pas ce n'est pas un
objectif il faut au contraire se fixer
des objectifs de manière raisonnée et
quantifier et ensuite mettre en place
les structures nécessaires pour que ses
objectifs se réalise je laisse la parole
à pierre pour la partie deuxième partie
sur les investissements dans
l'efficacité énergétique merci je vais
essayer d'être rapide pour pour finir
nos présentations on je vais continuer
sur les investissements et notamment sur
le sujet de l'efficacité énergétique est
sans doute le le secteur où les montants
en investissement possible sans les plus
importants en fonction des objectifs que
nous nous fixons sur l'efficacité
énergétique aujourd'hui la commission
européenne s'est fixé un objectif de 27
% d'efficacité énergétique d'ici 2030
peut être 30 % si elle est révisée sans
doute suite à la cap 21 qui pourra
permettre de revoir nos objectifs
notamment en termes climatique et
derrière nos objectifs énergétiques
les outils qui sont dans le projet de
loi sur la transition énergétique sont
intéressants très intéressant même avec
des outils nouveaux comme les budgets
carbone qui vont permettre de décliner
des objectifs climatiques par secteur ce
qui n'était pas encore fait de manière
suffisamment précise et qui devra aussi
indiquer les moyens à mettre en place et
dans les moyens il y a les
investissements les économies d'énergie
sont sans doute un secteur où les
investissements aujourd'hui peuvent être
lancés massivement avec des retombées
économiques significatives et aussi
d'autres qu'aux bénéfices des bénéfices
en termes d'emploi des bénéfices de
réduction des dépenses publiques dès
aussi des gains sanitaires pour un
certain nombre d'investissements le gaz
sanitaires et sociaux lorsqu'on investit
dans la précarité énergétique et aussi
des investisse des bénéfices en termes
de compétitivité de notre secteur
industriel
si on décline par secteur la le projet
de loi le projet de loi le donne un
certain nombre de levier pour soutenir
l'investissement
dans les transports dans le bâtiment
dans l'industrie donc par secteur dans
les transports en fait il faut bien voir
que les besoins d'investissement
aujourd'hui
sont à la fois des investis
d'investissement dans les
infrastructures dans les infrastructures
de transports en commun sont sans doute
une priorité faut bien regarder les
bénéfices socio économiques attendues de
ces investissements et aussi ne pas
oublier comme ceux jancovici la cité des
investissements qui peuvent être
relativement
moins moins lourd avec des retombées
importantes comme par exemple des voies
réservées pour les bus en entrée de
ville
c'est aussi des investissements dans le
renouvellement des matériels le projet
de loi donne un certain nombre de deux
mesures qui vont de d'obligations pour
le renouvellement vers dvd véhicules
propres il prévoit aussi de favoriser
des mesures de réglementation des villes
pour
favoriser progressivement incité
progressivement avoir d'aidé à l'achat
de véhicules moins polluants il ne
faudra pas oublier la nécessité de
soutenir aussi l'investissement dans la
recherche et développement puisque il
reste un certain nombre d'incertitudes
sur des sites et sur les d les
motorisations qui prendront la plus de
parts dans les transports demain
n'oublions pas enfin les investissements
dans les formes urbaines si on veut
réussir à faire des économies d'énergie
à long terme il faudra réussir à
rapprocher des les logements des emplois
et avoir des politiques de planification
urbaine qui prenne en compte ces enjeux
de mixité urbaine pour pour favoriser
progressivement une réduction des
déplacements contraints il ya donc une
cohérence à avoir entre des politiques
d'aménagement et les politiques d les
objectifs des politiques énergétiques
très rapidement je passe au bâtiment
avec deux approches qui sont nécessaires
je pense qu'il faut bien les
différencier une approche de soutien aux
rénovations ambitieuse des logements qui
doit en particulier ciblé les logements
du parc social public et privé et puis
il y à aussi la nécessité de diffuser
des nouvelles technologies performantes
et ça ça pourra se faire comme ça a été
soulignée en embarquant la performance
énergétique dans les travaux qui sont
déjà réalisé des travaux de rénovation
qui sont déjà réalisés manière massive
qui est d'ailleurs un rythme qui s'est
réduit en raison de la crise il faut
trouver les moyens de stimuler la
rénovation alors il y a des obligations
pour mettre de la performance
énergétique dans les travaux de
rénovation classiques qui sont dans ce
projet pas il faut réfléchir aller plus
loin et avoir des obligations de
rénovation énergétique qui pourrait
effectivement stimuler et stimuler les
marchés de la rénovation énergétique on
a parlé des projets du projet présenté
par shi project et la fondation nicolas
hulot pour pour le faire dans le
patrimoine public c'est certain que dans
le cadre du plan juncker ça sera un
levier potentiellement majeur pour
soutenir l'investissement public
notamment l'investissement des
collectivités locales qui
qui qui ont effectivement un
un patrimoine sur lequel d un gisement
d'économies d'énergie particulièrement
rentable en termes d'économies pour
demain
qu'il faut pouvoir soutenir et la
mobilisation aussi des outils financiers
qui seront mis en place dans le plan de
la commission européenne comme vie à
l'abbaye seront à
sont articulés avec attention enfin
l'efficacité énergétique dans
l'industrie peut doit servir des
objectifs de politique industrielle en
prenant en compte des enjeux de
compétitivité
dans certains cas on pourra les choix
devront être faits pour soutenir des
secteurs intensifs en énergie mais si il
faut aussi veiller à améliorer la
compétitivité de nos industries même les
plus intensives en énergie via
d'efficacité énergétique je vais donc
très brièvement arrivée sur notre
conclusion pour pour souligner
l'importance de cette de la
planification à travers les outils qui
sont proposés par là par le projet de
loi la stratégie bas carbone les budgets
carbone et les la planification
pluriannuelle de l'énergie
il faut voir c'est cette c'est cette
ambition comme un c'est cette
planification il faut la voir comme un
levier pour réussir l'investissement je
pense que j'insiste on insiste ensemble
sur l'investissement dans la transition
énergétique à la fois parce que c'est un
levier de sortie de crise et aussi parce
que c'est une de ses ambitions soit un
moyen de montrer notre crédibilité par
rapport aux enjeux climat et notamment
par rapport à la coop 21 l'année
prochaine qui est sera organisée à paris
pour que ces jeux nous assistons aussi
sur sur ces enjeux d'investissement pour
dire que regarder l'ensemble des
dispositions qui sont proposées dans ce
projet de loi de réglementation
d'incitation
d'amélioration de la réglementation est
aussi de nouvelles obligations on
regarde la manière dont ça peut stimuler
dans les différents secteurs
d'investissement et nous aider à jouer
un effet de levier pour la relance de
l'économie je pense que il ne faut plus
avoir peur aujourd'hui de d'accroître
ses obligations de développer de
nouvelles incitations comme là mais
comme les possibilités de modulation des
droits de mutation dès qu' on est en
capacité de démontrer que ce sera qu'ils
constitueront des leviers à
l'investissement et enfin puisque nous
sommes au sénat je conclus sur la
l'urgence de relancer l'investissement
au niveau local vous savez sans doute
que il ya des grandes inquiétudes sur la
baisse de l'investissement au niveau
local et que pour soutenir
pour soutenir et redresser cet
investissement le cas de la transition
énergétique peut constituer un levier à
condition il me semble de veiller à la
meilleure articulation une meilleure
gouvernance donc il y à des mesures dans
ce projet de loire monsieur gosselin a
cité les mesures d
évolution des compétences aussi qui sont
dans les lois de décentralisation et qui
sont dans le projet de loi sur la
nouvelle organisation territoriale de la
république il faut veiller une
articulation avec peut-être deux sans
doute même certainement pour nous de
notre point vue de niveau clé pour la
transition énergétique la planification
a été cité au niveau régional et ne pas
oublier les intercommunalités qui
doivent pouvoir monter en compétences et
articulé l'ensemble des politiques liées
à la transition énergétique qui ne sont
pas que des compétences énergétique qui
doivent mobiliser des compétences de
planification urbaine les compétences de
logements des compétences aussi dans
développement économique la région doit
les accompagner sur développement
économique ce rapport formation
professionnelle et favoriser
favoriser cette montée en compétence et
la lutte contre des fsi locon rencontre
aujourd'hui dans les collectivités
locales pour avoir de véritables
stratégies d'investissement au service
de la transition énergétique je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur muscle ou c'est
bien de rappeler que nous sommes au
sénat parce que je montais moi même le
rappeler je les fais tout à l'heure
qu'il est c'est vrai qu'au sénat on se
on se préoccupe non seulement de la
transition énergétique ce qui est le
coeur de la vocation de notre commission
mais on se préoccupe aussi des
collectivités locales est une des
difficultés qu'on a aujourd'hui quand on
quand on envisage des investissements
nécessaires à la transition énergétique
c'est comme l'on souffle et un certain
nombre de collègues avec quoi parce que
peut-être la différence entre vous et
nous nous on est pour la majorité
d'entre nous aux manettes de
collectivités locales on a subi une
première baisse de dotation 2014 qui
n'est rien à côté de ce qui nous attend
en 2015 2016 et 2017 où ça va vraiment
être je dis pas ça d'un point de vue
politicien est vraiment parce que c'est
la réalité ça va être d'une brutalité
redoutable et même si on sait que ces
investissements je parle même pas de
l'impact en termes de transition
énergétique mais même si on sait qu'à
terme ils vont pouvoir permettre de
générer des économie si on n'a pas la
capacité de les réaliser je vois pas
comment on fait parce que pour faire
l'investissement c'est la différence
avec l'état on peut pas on peut pas
creuser les déficits on obligé d'avoir
un minimum d'excédent de fonctionnement
et je peux vous assurer sans jouer les
oiseaux de mauvaise augure que plus ça
va aller moi on va avoir de capacité
d'investissement et qu'il y a même des
communes notamment dans les plus petites
d'entre elles qui n'arriveront même pas
dans les années qui viennent équilibrer
leur section de fonctionnement donc
c'est une des difficultés
qui se répercute notamment sur cet
impact transition énergétique qui
nécessite des investissements importants
dont je remets pas bien sûr en cause la
nécessité et l'utilité simplement quand
on n'a pas d'argent pour les réaliser
c'est un peu compliqué et je voudrais
dire avant de passer la parole à louis
appui à mes différents collet que
parce qu'on a justement le souci la
vocation de représenter les
collectivités locales on est forcément
assez sensible et et à ces mêmes
employés nos irritable sur tout ce qui
peut conduire à des normes nouvelles je
crois qu'à certains d'entre vous l'ont
dit et et je parle sous le contrôle de
rémy pointereau qui en tant que premier
vice-président de la négation
collectivités locales et spécifiquement
chargé d'essayer de simplifier les
normes et dieu sait qu'il y en a et dieu
sait que c'est pas facile on est très
irritable sur tout ce qui concerne les
contraintes nouvelles compos impose aux
communes les sanctions certains d'entre
vous ont proposé de remettre quelques
sanctions supplémentaires aux
collectivités locales sur l'augmentation
des coûts j'en ai j'en ai dit un mot et
puis je vais même un peu plus loin moi
sur tout ce qui est du domaine de la
décision imposée aux communes
je prends l'exemple que l'on connaît
bien dans nos territoires des éoliennes
vous avez dit l'un d'entre vous a dit
qu'il fallait passer de l'autorisation
au simple enregistrement
moi personnellement mais je dis bien
personnellement je trouve ça quand même
très difficile pour pas dire plus que
l'on ne peut que l'on mette en place
d'éoliennes quand les élus sont pas
d'accord parce que à quoi ça sert d'être
élu d'une commune si des décisions aussi
importantes que cela sont faites contre
votre volonté
donc voilà je crois qu'il faut on est
chacun dans notre rôle mais il faut
essayer de trouver des points
d'équilibré parce que oui il faut
développer les énergies renouvelables
pour rester sur l'exemple des éoliennes
d'éoliennes mais en même temps
c'est comme les élus qui sont
responsables du devenir de leur commune
et qui ensuite en sont responsables
devant devant les électeurs alors je
sais ce que je dis n'est pas forcément
compatible avec ce que vous pensez mais
je voulais quand même le dire je donne
la parole tout de suite à louis et
ensuite on aura pas voilà
merci monsieur le président vous voyez
mesdames et messieurs que vous êtes au
sénat et vous êtes avec des collègues
qui ceux qui ont les pieds sur terre qui
tous les jours se coltine à des
difficultés pour autant on a besoin de
vous on a besoin de vous inviter voilà
on a besoin de vous parce que vous
secouer le cocotier vous pouvez vous
permettre vous êtes hors sol quelque
part et et non non non c'est un avantage
c'est un avantage de pouvoir justement
avoir un dialogue avec des gens qui sont
sur le terrain à longueur de temps qui
se heurte à certaines difficultés qui
accepte mal et ils ont bien raison que
les collectivités et les élus ne soient
pas reconnues comme tel bond et en même
temps des citoyens français qui
réfléchit ce qu'ils pensent et qui ont
justement la possibilité de faire passer
un certain nombre de messages alors à
mon niveau à moi j'ai retenu
qu'il y avait un problème de cohérence
par exemple entre les réseaux demain
décentralisée et puis le niveau national
où on se heurte à deux philosophies
incontestablement la philosophie
traditionnelle jeu que je qualifierais
de jacobine c'est anciens et
l'aspect girondins de l'économie
décentralisée de la production
décentralisée qui est une réponse
effectivement au problème global
aujourd'hui de la répartition de
l'énergie donc je trouve que c'est une
question pertinente et
nous pouvons encore continuer avec la
gouvernance qui gouvernent
à quel niveau et là encore avec quel
problème je dirai quel aspect de
cohérence entre ce que nous pouvons
avoir et cette taupe d'hommes qui
descend et qui va s'imposer on voit les
réactions du sénat et donc des
collectivités locales surtout les
schémas prescriptif qui n'ont pas
bénéficié
conformément à ce que vous avez dit les
uns les autres nous vous rejoignons là
dessus sur la démocratie locale où on a
besoin de concertation notamment avec
nos populations nous imposer quelque
chose c'est contraire à l'orientation
que nous élus locaux souhaitant donc ce
deuxième aspect là est un aspect que je
retiens qui montre qu'il y a une
certaine c'est un diagnostic qui est
semblable ensuite vous avez évoqué le
problème de la simplification et de là
c'est le choc de simplification et c'est
vrai que rémy qui à ce travail de choc
de simplification to dry de tite art or
nous nous heurtons à cette diversité non
seulement de plans de termes qui forment
que plus personne s'y retrouve donc là
encore je considère que les remarques
que vous avez fait ce sont des remarques
pour moi de bon sens tout simplement
donc il y a dans ce domaine là de quoi
faire et sur la gouvernance vous l'avez
dit et on essaiera d'améliorer un peu
les choses en s'appuyant peut-être sur
le conseil constitutionnel mais je crois
qu'au nez dans un domaine sur lequel
visiblement y compris le débat public
que nous avons reçue à l'audition
considère qu'il y a dans ce domaine là
vraisemblablement des modifications à
apporter pour permettre à la fois deux
objectifs principaux qui sont d'une part
la concertation il faut que les gens
aujourd'hui on est au 21ème siècle on a
besoin de nos concitoyens de leur avis
de leurs observations mais en même temps
il faut aller plus vite dans nos projets
il faut effectivement d autorisation
unique et il faut pas gêner
continuellement pendant 10 ans pour
arriver à sortir en projet donc non
seulement on a un problème de norme mais
en plus on a un problème de démocratie
locale à la fois qu'il faut respecter et
en même temps on a un souci de principe
de réalité pour sortir ces
investissements que vous avez à juste
raison si t'es bon nous avons un urgent
besoin et donc il faut trouver où on va
mettre le curseur est vraisemblablement
là il va falloir faire preuve d'un peu
d'imagination les uns les autres vous
avez parlé de la fiscalité au quel beau
sujet que voilà la fiscalité vous l'avez
entendu le président l'a dit l'état
d'esprit des collectivités locales mais
au delà des français c'est un ras-le-bol
général
si nous n'y prenons pas garde je l' ai
dit hier au ministre de l'intérieur
si nous n'y prenons pas garde nous
allons favoriser les extrêmes parce que
des français de base à nos ras-le-bol
bon alors ce qu'il faut faire c'est à
périmètre constant par racheter
mais à périmètre constant faire évoluer
la fiscalité vous l'avez suggéré et vous
l'avez dit également faire évoluer
progressivement la fiscalité vers une
fiscalité carbone ça c'est clair parce
que vous l'avez encore dit là aussi et
tout le monde de la bien entendu que
l'essentiel de l'énergie dans ce pays ne
venait pas de l'énergie nucléaire
revenez du fossile voilà ça vienne des
énergies fossiles collin porte à plus de
70 hier d'euros par an et sur lequel
peut-être il y aurait un effort plus
important à réaliser surtout surtout si
nous voulons faire de transition
énergétique et surtout si nous voulons
essayer après la couverture d'avoir
appris qu'au besoin d'avoir une coque
20h dans lequel lima
c'est pas très très bien terminé bon
j'espère que ça ira mieux ici à paris
entre les cases ses 190 pays qui vont
venir à paris et je préférerais que pour
notre pays on arrive à s'entendre sur ce
changement climatique qui entraîne qui
entraîne et là aussi je crois que il
faut être honnête non seulement il ya
plus d'argent dans les caisses mais en
plus on va demander aux français de
changer de comportement
d'évoluer dans ce domaine là parce que
sinon nous ne pourrons pas atteindre ses
objectifs de -2° le climat et si nous
les attendions pas on aura encore plus
de problèmes les économistes sont
d'accord le nous risquons d'avoir en
dépenses justement due à cette moindre
efficacité dans ce domaine nous risquons
d'avoir des dépenses beaucoup plus
importantes que prévu donc quelqu'un les
paiera il vaut mieux s'engager là dessus
et je terminerai en disant que vous avez
une vision sur la planification
pluriannuelle qui nous paraît aller dans
le bon sens dans ce domaine de la alors
moi j'avais peut-être aussi deux ou
trois questions complémentaires vous
poser finalement un chapitre important
qui tient à la santé on dirait la santé
c'est peut-être un détail mais j'ai été
étonné j'ai été étonné que aucun de vous
ne met autant l'accent sur la qualité de
l'air et donc pas sur la qualité de
l'air premier degré sur la santé de nos
concitoyens
si les chinois actuellement sont en
train de bouger c'est parce que les
grands responsables chinois
s'aperçoivent que sur leurs propres
poumons qui ont des problèmes ceux de
leurs épouses ceux de leurs enfants
donc nous avons dans notre pays nous
avons dans notre pays toute une série de
pics de pollution
au point que nous sommes aujourd'hui
j'avais dit rechercher un an procédure
avec la commission européenne
est-ce que ça mériterait pas que on s'en
occupe un tout petit peu sur
l'obsolescence programmée qui est un
sujet sur lequel les gens reviennent
souvent je vous ai pas entendu non plus
et alors sur des tâches vais terminer
par un détail vous allez voir ce n'est
jamais le sixième continent mais ce
fameux sacs en plastique à usage unique
qui l'a aussi attire beaucoup beaucoup
l'attention des uns et des autres je
n'ai rien entendu là-dessus voilà
merci beaucoup je vais donner la parole
un billion
merci monsieur le président donc je vous
remercie pour vos différentes
interventions évidemment ma question
s'adresse plus à monsieur jancovici
lorsqu'il disait être favorable à une
obligation de rénovation lorsqu'il ya de
la rénovation intégré obligatoirement
cette rénovation énergétique donc n'avez
vous pas peur en réalité que cette
obligation fasse que des travaux ne se
feront pas compte tenu du coût donc je
crois que les réponses en général ça
intervient à la je crois monsieur le
président toutes les réponses
interviennent à la fin oui voilà
donc voilà n'avez vous pas peur que du
coût des ces travaux ne se fasse pas et
que faire alors quand le prix du
bâtiment sera moins élevé sa valeur
sera moins élevé que le prix des travaux
quel intérêt pour le propriétaire de
s'engager dans des travaux alors que son
bâtiment est déjà n'a pas une grande
valeur pour après l'évaluation du prix
du bâtiment pour a valu et variés pardon
entre l'avis des domaines l'avis d'une
agence
immobilière donc qu'elle quel prix à
partir de quel prix 7 ces travaux seront
jugés faisable ou non faisable
qu'en sera-t-il puisqu'on le rend
obligatoire qu'en sera-t-il des
obligations à la fois techniques et des
contraintes techniques des contraintes
juridiques puisque il ya certaines
villes qui ont déjà des pp a eu et il ya
les bâtiments qui sont protégés donc à
partir du moment dès qu'ils toucheront
bâtiment ils seront obligés de faire de
la rénovation énergétique mais peut-être
que les textes à la fois l'épée et lui
les aides ppa huppé et les bâtiments de
france ne les empêcheront d'aller vers
ça et
dernier point question des compétences
alors on en revient à un petit peu on en
parle systématiquement mais plusieurs
intervenants sont sont évoqués les
objectifs et les compétences région et a
donc je crois vraiment que les moyens
qui vont être à mettre en oeuvre seront
différents selon qu'il s'agira soit de
l'état soit dirigé des régions donc je
partage complètement la remarque de
monsieur gosses mais lorsque il disait
que la loi notre et la loi de transition
énergétique devait être reliés
merci monsieur michael va prendre que
trois quatre questions et puis après on
répondra
layrac de questions merci monsieur le
président
quelques remarques et questions sur
la politique des déchets par le
lendemain que président du conseil
national des déchets
les rep
sont un très bon système
qui est aujourd'hui inégalée dans le
monde
nous devons le préserver
et le préserver
parce que j'ai quelques inquiétudes sur
le sujet par l'arrivée d'opérateurs
étrangers qui voudraient venir récupérer
nos produits si on veut faire l'économie
circulaire il faut commencer par trier
nos déchets
totalement les valoriser dans notre
territoire et là nous avons deux
catégories de rep les reps financière et
leur ep opérationnel les rêves
financières sont intéressantes parce que
les collectivités ont une certaine prise
sur ces opérations elles peuvent choisir
alors que les rep opérationnel massifie
beaucoup trop et laisse les
collectivités saint pratiquement sans
moyens pour assurer la collecte de ces
produits
est un sujet que je veux aborder sur
l'énergie
nous avons une ressource d'énergie
considérable dans ce pays c'est la
biomasse qui est sous utilisé que nous
nous mobilisons nous mobilisons mal
alors que nous en avons à profusion et
que celle là elle est renouvelable
l'eau le boisement gagne gagne gagne
gagne et au nom de la protection de
l'environnement il ne faudrait rien
touché
alors ou
non mais
c'est peut-être vrai
du matin chez moi il faut construire la
filière économique il faut la construire
nous y travaillons dans certains
départements parce que j'ai entendu
aussi les remarques ont été faites sur
la région la grande région et la
communauté de communes mais il ya bien
un niveau intermédiaire juin anciens
présidents de conseil général alors j'ai
quelques souvenirs du travail que j'ai
fait en matière de rénovation de
bâtiments de mise à niveau de bâtiments
et des économies ont été réalisées parce
que nous menions des politiques de
proximité qui était maîtrisée par les
élus locaux et qui n'était pas dictée de
de dociles web alors les normes bien sûr
il ya les normes il ya leur
interprétation qui est faite par les
services de l'état
nous avons des services qui ne sont du
service facilitateur parfois nous avons
des services qui sont là pour faire du
pointillisme administratif et qui nous
empêche de réaliser dans des conditions
normales le diesel
alors le diesel il faut le bannir mais
n'allons quand même pas trop vite parce
que dans des territoires comme les
nôtres moi je suis en zone rurale mon
accent nous a compris que j'étais pas
parisien
dans nos territoires ruraux nous avons
des gens qui
habitent à 15km leur travail et qui pour
ceux des plats qui ont de petits
salaires qui pour se déplacer le petit
véhicule diesel parce que c'est plus
économique alors faisons bien attention
de ne pas pénaliser de ne pas trop
pénaliser ces gens là alors ensuite il
faut aussi voir le diesel
la pollution du diesel nous avons les
transports
et camions nombreux nous avons les
trains cantona des lignes qui ne sont
pas électrifiés
il ya des machines diesel nous avons
tous les matériels de travaux publics
alors ces équipements d'évoluer les
derniers véhicules diesel les véhicules
automobiles sont équipés de filtres à
nox et de filtres à particules et
consomment beaucoup moins qu'il ne
consommait il ya quelques années alors
cette transition il faut la faire nous
allons avoir un véhicule hybride à air
comprimé moi je compte beaucoup sur ces
évolutions technologiques
mais on ne peut pas mettre à la poubelle
directement
qu'on connaît le transfert de véhicules
vers les véhicules plus propres oui mais
attention à ne pas faire une guerre
insensée au diesel c'est vrai qu'il faut
diminuer la consommation de pétrole et
si nous travaillons avec la biomasse
nous y parviendrons
la baisse de la vitesse à grand débat
m'écouter cantonnés dans des territoires
comme les miens aussi
j'ai pas mis comme mais c'est la vitesse
à 80 à l'heure sur toutes les routes il
faudrait peut-être avoir l'intelligence
de classer les routes en fonction de
leur état
cantona une route départementale toute
droite qu'on roule à 90 60 sa change pas
grand chose un bon et rouler à 100 à
l'heure par contre on a des routes où on
pourrait baisser la vitesse jeunes nice
parce qu'elles sont très tortueux est
sinueuse et je crois qu'il faudrait
adapter tout ça en tout cas sur les
autos de restons à 130 à l'heure je vous
en prie parce que à ce moment là ce sera
là une vision de l'interdît voilà mais
j'ai à peu près j'avais près tout dit
ainsi un mot sur les déchets que
pensez-vous de la taxe d'enlèvement des
ordures ménagères je considère que c'est
un système complètement inadaptés
aujourd'hui
pour faire payer un service nous devrons
nous devrions faire payer ce service à
son juste prix et il est bien évident
que là aussi on ne peut pas mettre la
tarification incitative partout parce
que quand on donne à cette habitants au
kilomètre carré on va aller chercher la
poubelle oomu de la colline à 3 km
donc on a des adaptations à trouver mais
l'a t om est un système que je considère
inadaptée que nous devons revoir
merci je vais donner par là monsieur
d'ortec
merci monsieur le président quelques
points mais si on est rapide d'abord bon
je note quand même que de l'ensemble des
interventions
la question de la planification
énergétique française dans un système
européen les revenus de manière
systématique et ce qui se joue
aujourd'hui
c'est bien la capacité de l'état à
retrouver une stratégie énergétique et
une planification énergétique ce qui l'a
perdu au fil du temps depuis les depuis
les années 70 c'est peut-être un point
qui pourrait faire relatif consensus
entre différentes familles politiques
entre entre gaullistes et écolo on doit
pouvoir se retrouver sur une idée de
planification je suis quand même pour
avoir suivi quand même cette question d'
extrêmement près puisque je préside le
groupe de travail gouvernance du débat
national qu'on a failli avoir une
planification à trois ans que il ya eu
un pré projet de loi qui considérait
qu'on pouvait planifié l'énergie sur
trois ans ce qui était évidemment
totalement ridicule on est passé à 10
ans révisable tous les 5 ans et le
rythme politique c'est probablement
encore insuffisant je pense que la
logique serait plutôt d'une
planification à 20 ans révisable tous
les dix ans ça serait probablement le à
la logique mais je crois que le
compromis
aujourd'hui hélas est en tout cas de ce
que j'entends je pense que personne ne
reviendra en arrière sur le fait de
redonner à l'état une capacité stratège
et effectivement dans les conclusions du
du débat national et du groupe que je
présidais on avait bien mis et qu'il
fallait un comité d'experts à côté
du lieu de la décision et donc je note
bien que cette proposition est toujours
sur la table je pense qu'effectivement
il faut il faut qu'on ait ce regard
extérieur et qu'on remet de la
planification aucun remède la
planification au coeur ça veut bien dire
que c'est l'état la puissance publique y
compris la représentation parlementaire
puisque on dit bien que cette paix peut
devrait aussi être soumises au parlement
qui reprend la main et non pas un ou
deux opérateurs énergétiques qui on a
délégué un petit peu la planification en
france depuis un certain nombre d'années
à partir de là juste peut-être un petit
point pour dire
monsieur jancovici que je connais bien
que on a quand même bien deux enjeux on
a eu quand même bien on a un hors-jeu
sur le fossile on est tout à fait
d'accord enfin tout à fait d'accord
n'est globalement d'accord parce que sur
ses retombées de propos en débattre à
l'infini mais qu' il faut pas penser
qu'on a pas d'enjeu sur l'électrique on
a un système électrique français
vieillissant fondée sur un parc
nucléaire qui arrive aux 40 ans un don
on n'est pas certain techniquement
aujourd'hui qu'il est capable de
continuer c'est pas vrai on ne le sait
pas ailleurs en europe il ya des
centrales qui s'arrête à 40 ans parce
qu'elles ne peuvent pas continuer que
c'est donc des investissements massifs
dans les dix prochaines années et ne pas
considérer qu'on a un enjeu électrique
aussi important que le fossile ne tient
absolument pas la réalité des enjeux
d'investissement français des prochaines
années donc on a bien deux enjeux
quasiment demain importance économique
en termes de volume d'investissement qui
sont le fossile et qui sans l'électrique
à et que sur l'électrique on a en plus à
re rentrer le système électrique
français dans le système européen avec
des difficultés énormes puisque le
système électrique français n'est pas
conçu dans le système européen mais un
système auto conçue et qu'aujourd'hui il
faut leur entrée dans le système
européen et que ça c'est extrêmement
compliqué il comprit rien que la
question des mécanismes de capacité à
l'échelle européenne qui qui ferait
faire une économie extrêmement
importante en termes d'investissement
demain pour assurer la sécurité du
système électrique
on voit bien la difficulté aujourd'hui
leur rentrée à l'échelle européenne
c'est un peu technique mais c'est
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
qui sont derrière le fait de savoir si
on a un mécanisme de capacités plutôt
français ou sur un petit espace autour
de la france aussi en un vrai système de
mécanismes de capacité à l'échelle
européenne ça ce sont des questions qui
se traduisent en terme d'investissement
par des centaines de millions d'euros et
derrière ça se retrouve évidemment sur
la facture notamment sur les suspects
donc donc un enjeu fort sur la
planification et j'espère que le sénat
renforcera la capacité planification un
objet énergétique dans ce pays derrière
bon nous avions insisté dans ce groupe
de travail énormément sur la question de
la du rôle des collectivités
territoriales ça a été dit beaucoup
c'est évidemment un enjeu absolument
essentiel avec un couple je crois pas
qu'il faut il faut pas jouer plus région
au plus interco c'est vraiment un couple
et qu' il ya un élément de planification
régionale avec derrière y compris des
schémas développement économique mais le
gros du boulot je parle un peu comment
un ancien vice président d'une grande
métropole capitale verte de l'europe
c'est bien à l'échelle de l'interco que
va faire le gros du boulot et que c'est
bien à ce niveau là aujourd'hui il ya la
capacité d'action ce qui fait que ce qui
fait qu'on a un enjeu majeur
immédiat et ça ça ça fait qu est ce que
vous avez dit monsieur le président qui
est qu' il suffit pas dire il faut que
les collectivités y aille dans le
contexte financier
la capacité de sortir l'investissement
énergétique des collectivités de leur
taux d'endettement par exemple d'une
question centrale ça ça pourrait faire
une belle note de terrain de terra nova
ou d'un autre ici c'est à dire et
ségolène royal avait répondu
positivement
ma question là dessus lors de son
audition il faut qu'on trouve un
mécanisme pour qu'on ait effectivement
une capacité d'investissement en lien
avec l'abbé hui en lien avec l'argent
est disponible en fait l'argent est
disponible on n'utilise pas et que si on
réussit à trouver ce modèle là on peut
avoir des collectivités qui
s'investissent et qui derrière génère
énormément d'activité économique donc de
recettes fiscales y compris pour elle
même donc on est vraiment dans un cercle
vertueux mais il faut trouver la formule
magique
elle n'est pas évidente aujourd'hui par
rapport au code des collectivités
s'il en est puisque on a des
explorateurs de la terne qui trouve la
formule on va être extrêmement un
preneur derrière la question de
l'obligation de travaux la question de
l'obligation de travaux c'est
effectivement le coeur du rôle du
politique ou est ce qui met le curseur
entre obligation et simplification c'est
toute la question c'est toute la
question s'il n'y a pas d'obligation ya
pas de planification et ce qui fonde un
grand pays développé par rapport à un
pays émergent c'est sa capacité
d'obligations et c'est là dessus que ce
fait fondamentalement la différence
après il faut voir où sont les
obligations qui rapportent et où sont
les obligations qui ne rapporte pas
l'obligation de travaux l'obligation de
rénovation énergétique au moment des
travaux est typiquement une bonne
réponse puisque 11 il ya quelque chose
qui se fait obligatoirement c'est ça
qu'on encadre si on n'a pas ça si on n'a
pas ça on n'a pas les travaux ou de
manière secondaire qu'avec des
incitations et d'expériences sur les
territoires on n'y arrive pas et du coup
on ne crée pas les volumes qui créent
les filières économiques qui créent
justement la sortie de la dépendance
dont on a parlé donc donc revenir sur
cette obligation de travaux serait une
erreur tout à fait tragique pour
l'avenir de même qu'il est tragique pour
l'avenir de continuer à avoir un
discours sur le diesel on est dans un
tabou français hoog vraiment là le
politique se soit les gouvernements ou
les représentation parlementaire
considère que l'emploi est plus
important que les vingt trente mille
morts annoncés par par toutes les
enquêtes épidémiologiques
il ya un choix assumé aujourd'hui de la
puissance publique là dessus on préfère
la filière économique au coût en termes
de santé et c'est totalement assumée
mais sauf que sauf que ça ne marche pas
au sens où le diesel étant aujourd'hui
fléché comme dangereux les gens s'en
détournent quand même et à la fin de
l'histoire on aura ni la santé ni
le gain économique puisqu'on n'aura pas
anticiper sur les nécessaires évolutions
de filières et ça c'est clairement le
mal français c'est à dire cette
incapacité aujourd'hui de s'engager dans
les transitions de retarder les
échéances et un certain conservatisme
français dont senna montrera lors de la
loi la discussion de la loi qu'il n'est
pas évidemment le défense très bien je
donne la parole à monsieur vaspart
merci monsieur le président moi je
commencerai par ce que nous a dit terra
nova et
samassa masse et plus parce que vous
avez dit tout à l'heure que vous
sembliez totalement démuni sur les
perspectives ou ou plus exactement la
projection où vous pourriez faire sur le
découpe découplage consommation
d'énergie et croissance c'est je crois
tout le problème
c'est toute la difficulté que nous avons
avec les populations
c'est à dire que on ne sait pas
exactement où nous va où on va on nous
propose un changement de vie en
définitive ça a été rappelé tout à
l'heure par les uns et les autres mais
sans savoir si ça va coûter de l'emploi
si ça va en créer quelle est l'évolution
de quelle va être l'évolution de la vie
des gens etc c'est tout le problème de
l'acceptabilité
des populations et c'est ça à mon avis
le proc l'un des problèmes principaux
si on va trop loin c'est dans la rue que
ça se passera c'est exactement comme ça
que ça se passera alors attention je
vous le dis tel que je l' ai ressenti
fortement ce matin attention je crois
qu'on est tous ceux décidés à faire des
efforts mais à condition que ces efforts
soient
supportables par l'ensemble de la
population de notre pays qui a déjà en
ce domaine fait beaucoup d'efforts par
rapport à bien d'autres je voudrais
revenir un instant sur ce qui a été dit
également sur les schémas régionaux
prescriptif
le problème c'est que dans les projets
de loi que je que nous percevons
aujourd'hui on met tout et n'importe
quoi et il faut voter la loi telle
qu'elle est or on mélange excusez moi
mais les carottes et des navets dans les
lois maintenant on parle de tout et
après il faut se prononcer or on
pourrait avoir les consensus sur telle
ou telle chose et peut-être pas sur
d'autres donc attention prescriptif nous
on n'en veut pas sur tout ce qui touche
à l'urbanisme sur un schéma qui eux
seraient un schéma
de maîtrise de l'énergie au plan local
ou d'évolution de la transition
énergétique au plan régional
pourquoi pas mais pas lorsqu'on arrive
véritablement dans les compétences des
intercommunalités
j'ai entendu également tout à l'heure
qu'il fallait renforcer la concertation
pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas et notamment qu'elle
n'était pas forcément au bon endroit je
suis prêt à partager cette analyse mais
à condition ne pas faire de ne pas la
doubler ou à tripler parce qu'à ce
moment là vous ne simplifiée pas vous
compliquer les procédures et si on
compliquer les procédures ont les
allonges et si on les allons chez de
l'investissement qu'on ne réalisent pas
ou qu'on diffère dans le temps et donc
c'est de l'emploi en moins tout ça est
entièrement liée
entièrement lié et puis je vais finir
sur le diesel et notamment par ce qui a
été dit tout à l'heure et je parte
abeilles est parti mais l'opinion d'un
des collègues qui a été exprimée tout à
l'heure
il faut qu'on fasse attention nous élus
mais vous vous êtes peut-être plus
avertis que nous élus sur les évolutions
technologiques mais il y a aussi des
évolutions technologiques
l'homme est intelligent il sait remettre
en cause ses faiblesses et les
difficultés qu'il a perçus et on ne doit
pas minimiser l'évolution technologique
qu'on est capable d'assumer et que les
entreprises privées les constructeurs
automobiles est aussi aussi sont
capables de faire
d'après mes informations
aujourd'hui les véhicules diesel qui
sortent des chaînes de nos constructeurs
automobiles n'ont quasiment plus de
particules fines à la sortie de leurs
tuyaux ça demandera et sa demande des
expertises indépendantes
très clairement et il faudrait que nous
ayons des expertises indépendantes sur
nos tables
pas
voilà pour cette table ronde regroupant
des think tank spécialisé sur la
transition énergétique
vous avez pu entendre donc ses échanges
avec le sénat le sénat qui se prépare
depuis de longues semaines depuis de
longs mois à l'examen de ce texte en
séance publique néanmoins il faut savoir
qu'il ya très peu de chances pour que le
sénat de droite adopte ce texte dans les
termes proches de ceux de l'assemblée
nationale l'assemblée nationale qui a
adopté le projet de loi sur la
transition énergétique en première
lecture au mois d'octobre
rappelons également le contexte dans
lequel s'inscrit l'examen de ce projet
de loi celui de l'organisation à la fin
de l'année 2015 d'une grande un grand
sommet sur le climat regroupant plus de
190 pays qui doivent arriver à un accord
contraignant pour réduire l'émission des
gaz à effet de serre vous pouvez
toujours voir et revoir toutes les
auditions sur notre site publicsenat.fr
prochain rendez vous de l'actualité
parlementaire à 16h30 pour la suite de
la discussion en général sur le projet
de loi sur la nouvelle organisation
territoriale de la république très bonne
journée sur les chaînes parlementaires